Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Bist du schon in der neuen Geschichte angekommen?
Ich denke schon, denn ich will nicht nostalgisch werden. Okay. Das ist ja ein Vorwurf, ein Vorwurf, den die Autoren, die Autoren, wir nennen sie einmal Alex Hochschuli, George Hoare und Philipp Kahnleff uns machen oder zumindest machen sie einigen in der Bevölkerung diesen Vorwurf, dass sie nostalgisch werden. Und die Frage ist ja, wo kommt man denn eigentlich an, wenn man am Ende der Geschichte plötzlich erklären muss, dass die Geschichte doch nicht zu Ende ist und die Autoren versuchen, uns aber zu zeigen, dass das gar nicht so ungewöhnlich ist. Also wenn man nochmal auf dieses Konzept vom Ende der Geschichte zurückgeht, was ist damit eigentlich gemeint, dann ist damit schon mal nicht gemeint, dass man tatsächlich in so einem paradiesischen Zustand ankommt. Und sie lesen ja Fukuyama nochmal und versuchen dann von dort aus weiterzugehen. Sie gehen aber auch nochmal kurz zu Hegel zurück. Darüber müssen wir auch sprechen. Aber fest steht ja schon mal, Fukuyama schreibt also diesen Artikel mit dem Ende des Kalten Krieges und sagt, wir haben das Ende der Geschichte erreicht. Die liberale Demokratie hat gesiegt. Und während ich gesiegt sage, muss ich gleich das ein bisschen zurücknehmen. Denn es ist kein triumphaler Artikel. Es ist kein Artikel, bei dem Fukuyama sagt, seht her, wir, die Guten, haben es geschafft. Sondern in diesem Artikel schwingt schon so etwas fast melancholisch Resignatives mit. Was bedeutet denn das jetzt? Also jetzt ist da keine Geschichtsdynamik mehr. Die Geschichte hat sich entfaltet. Ist das vielleicht ein unglaubliches Stadium der Langeweile, in das wir treten werden? Werden wir die heroischen Kämpfe eines Tages vermissen? So endet dann ja auch der Artikel.
Genau, der ist direkt von 89, also sozusagen ganz aktuell geschrieben, Mauerfall und so weiter. Und er lässt sich dann noch zwei Jahre Zeit und publiziert 2002 dann das Buch dazu, das aber im Tenor dem Artikel schon gleicht. Und bis heute ja die etwas wohl gerne nur Überschriftenleser in die Irre führt mit diesem, ja passiert denn jetzt nichts mehr, war die Geschichte echt zu Ende, es ging doch dann erst los und so. Was weiß ich, Bill Clinton Jahre, jetzt endlich der dritte Weg. Und das ist ja dann große Reflektionsschleife. Die die drei Autoren jetzt in ihrem Buch, die sind ungefähr so unser Alter, sind keine Italiener, ein Brasilianer, zwei Engländer. Da habe ich mich beim letzten Mal auch in die Irre führen lassen, weil ich dachte, der Bunker Bunker Podcast wird ja wohl von Italiener gemacht. Aber nein. Und nun habe ich nicht nochmal das Ende der Geschichte gelesen von Fukuyama. Mich hat aber trotzdem nochmal interessiert. Wie war das in diesem Buch? Also gucken wir noch mal kurz in die Geschichte des Endes der Geschichte, indem wir einfach den Wikipedia-Artikel nochmal aufrufen. Und da wird dann doch noch mal einiges klar. Also der Wikipedia-Artikel, der deutsche zu dem Fukuyama-Buch, ist sehr gut, klar strukturiert und fasst es auch nochmal gut zusammen. Wir haben es mit dem Kapitalismus zu tun, der sich nach dem Kalten Krieg durchgesetzt hat. Damit endete der große Kampf um die Anerkennung, also der Systemstreit, wie wir ihn jetzt gerade wieder sehen. Also China setzt eben Amerika gerade wirklich unter Druck, dadurch, dass sie da eben auch wirtschaftlich erfolgreich mit sind. Und damals jedenfalls vor 30 Jahren endete dieser, oder wir verloren diesen Antriebsmoment der Geschichte, so schreibt es Fukuyama. Also sozusagen unter der Haube, wo wir oben immer einfach sehen, was uns Journalisten erklären, was gestern passiert ist und so weiter. Da ist einfach strukturell so ein Motivationsantrieb Schwungrat verloren gegangen. Wir haben es also mit dem Ende der Geschichte zu tun. Und ab dann, sagt Fukuyama, also mit dem Mauerfall und mit der Auflösung der Sowjetunion und eben auch der Auflösung der ganzen Ideologie, haben wir es nur noch mit einer Integration und Assimilation nicht-westlicher Kulturen in die westliche Kultur zu tun, unter Preisgabe derer Grundsätze zugunsten von Freiheit und Menschenrechte. Dieses Metamorphose-Argument finde ich super wichtig, denn wir sehen mittlerweile, dass selbst die obskursten und merkwürdigsten Diktatoren immer noch so tun, als gäbe es eine Wahl. Die könnten ja auch einfach drüber stehen und sagen, ne, ich bin ja Diktator, ich wähle nicht. Aber nein, sie gaukeln uns immer noch diese Wahlen vor. Orwan macht es natürlich so unter diesem Begriff, nämlich gehört zur EU, da gehört es dann auch dazu. Aber auch die ganzen afrikanischen Länder, da gibt es interessante Soziologievorhaben, dann doch irgendwie, wenn man eine Universität gründet, dann nach westlichem Vorbild. So, ne, da gibt es verschiedene Fakultäten und so weiter.
Am deutlichsten kann man es sehen, wenn man sich nochmal Musikvideos ansieht aus den 90er Jahren. Wir haben jetzt sehr stark diese Debatte, cultural appropriation, wer darf Rasterzöpfe tragen und so weiter. Wenn man sich die 90er Jahre ansieht, dann wurde alles kulturelle aus anderen Kulturkreisen integriert in einen konsumistischen Hedonismus und alles war da möglich. Da tauchten die Ägypter plötzlich auf in den Musikvideos, tanzten zu irgendwelchen Hip-Hop-Beats auf dem Times Square. Also alles ist denkbar. Man muss sich nun mal solche Euro-Trash-Bands ansehen. Man muss sich ein paar Videos von Army of Lovers oder sowas ansehen. Und dann wird einem sofort auch klar, was Fukuyama hier meint. Das heißt, der liberaldemokratische Kapitalismus mit seinem konsumgetriebenen Subjekt hat gesiegt. Das bedeutet aber nicht, dass man alles andere ausschließt und dass man sagt, man will irgendwie eine westliche Reinheitskultur in irgendeiner Weise schaffen, sondern das meint, man macht die Metamorphose-Kultur. Alles kann einverleibt werden, alles kann gesampelt und geremixed werden.
Genau. Und das spielt sich alles auf sozusagen der semantischen Ebene statt, lässt die strukturelle Außen vor und das ist ja dann auch der große Kritik-Einfall. Ich würde sagen, es ist ein großer Wunsch eigentlich, dass jetzt das Ende des Endes der Geschichte ist von den drei Autoren. Also sie wünschen sich das so sehr, weil wir mit dem Ende der Geschichte politische Kritik und auch wirtschaftliche Kritik, also Kritik allgemein, eigentlich nur noch anhand von so Defiziten in der Umsetzung des sich durchgesetzten liberalen demokratischen Modells haben und gar keine Systemfragen mehr stellen. Niemals fragt man, wäre nicht auch eine andere Welt möglich und so weiter. Eine andere Welt ist denkbar, nee, ist sie nicht mehr, sondern wir haben uns jetzt irgendwie alle kollektiv geeinigt auf die liberale Demokratie und dockt dann nur noch an ihren Defiziten so ein bisschen rum. Und das war ja auch lange so, bis es jetzt eben, und da markieren sie ja dann 2016, das wird ganz interessant, dieses Jahr ist ja nun echt nicht ohne. Und Hegel und Marx spielen bei Fukuyama eine größere Rolle noch, als sie jetzt in dem neuen Buch nochmal aufgegriffen werden, denn die Geschichte als Geschichte von Kämpfen. Und dann dieses Syntheseargument, wo dann Fukuyama oder die drei Autoren jetzt Fukuyama nochmal so deuten, ja ja, Kommunismus, Kapitalismus und dann synthetisiert sich das zu Konsumismus. Also wir gehen alle nur noch einkaufen und kritisieren dann irgendwie, dass die Butter nicht, was weiß ich und so. Wir haben dann alle noch die Kritik an den einzelnen Sachen, aber so richtig Systemfragen stecken da nicht drin.
Es ist eine Verbraucherdemokratie und die Welt wird am Supermarktregal.
Genau, wenn es uns schlecht geht, dann weil wir schlecht versorgt werden, und da müsste man ja mal was ändern an den Idealen, die wir ja eigentlich schon durchgesetzt haben. Und Menschen suchen grundsätzlich nach Wohlstand und Freiheit. Das ist so Fukuyamas großes Einfallstor. Er glaubt, Nationalismus und Religionen werden bedeutungslos. Das war natürlich dann schon ab dem 11. September 2001 anders. Es gab diese Art der nicht Politisierung, sondern Poli Pol Polarisierung, dass es da verschiedene Einflugschneisen ins gesellschaftliche Leben gab. Und hier tauchte in diesem WGPT-Artikel ein Text, ein Satz auf, der ist mir gestern auch schon bei Twitter rausgerutscht, weil ich ihn wirklich unglaublich fand. Ich lese ihn mal im Original vor und schlage danach nur eine Änderung vor, die ich bei Twitter gestern auch schon mal markiert habe. Also das Buch wird vorgestellt, man liest diesen WGPT-Artikel und dann beginnt plötzlich dieser Abschnitt. Nach Fukuyama läuft es auf eine Gesellschaft hinaus, die ihre nach wie vor existenten aggressiven Energien nicht schöpferischer Arbeit, sondern im leeren Formalismus von Sport jeglicher Art verausgabt. Es bleibt die Fallhöhe, zurück zum Krieg zu degenerieren, allein aus Langeweile. Dafür sollte aber insbesondere der Erste Weltkrieg abschreckendes Beispiel sein. Zitat Ende. Wir sind gerade an diesem Punkt, in dem uns alle noch mal Christopher Clarks, die Schlafwandler zeigen. Um darauf hinzuweisen, wir haben es ja auch von dem 100-jährigen gehört, den du gespielt hast, ich habe seinen Namen vergessen. Troller, ja. Ja, Weltkriege beginnen immer klein, aber dann wird halt irgendwo eine Grenze überschritten und dann denkt sich irgendwer, ach, der unterstütze ich auch nochmal und dann denkt sich jemand, ach, den unterstütze ich dann auch nochmal und zack, ist es ein Weltkrieg. Wir sind also irgendwie doch in so einer Region gerade angekommen, bei der wir von der Fallhöhe zurück zum Krieg zu degenerieren. Also das passiert ja gerade. Wir degenerieren ja wirklich gerade zum Glück. Nur es ist nicht der Sport, an dem wir unsere Kräfte verschwenden, sondern es ist Social Media.
Sport war ja gar nicht möglich.
Genau.
Sport war nicht möglich. Die Leute blieben zu Hause. Und da sind die Sportvereine nicht da. Aber das Problem ist ja ohnehin schon, dass die sozialen Medien auch schon vor Corona extrem dominant waren. Ja und liest doch bitte noch einmal diese Stelle vor und sag, das schiebst du nur ein mit dem Social Media. Dann wird es nämlich nochmal richtig klar.
Genau, dann lesen wir den kleinen Abstand nochmal. Also nach Fukuyama läuft es auf eine Gesellschaft hinaus, die ihre nach wie vor existenten aggressiven Energien nicht schöpferische Arbeit, sondern im leeren Formalismus von Social Media jeglicher Art verausgabt. Es bleibt die Fallhöhe, zurück zum Krieg zu degenerieren, allein aus Langeweile. Dafür sollte aber insbesondere der Erste Weltkrieg abschreckendes Beispiel sein. Und man erschrickt so ein bisschen, wenn man das liest. Also das ist nicht gut. Und da wir jetzt einen Krieg haben, Fukuyama hat am 20. März nochmal ein Interview gegeben. Ganz aktuell, wo er, oder was heißt ein Interview, es war ein Text, in dem Zitate von ihm auftauchen zu den aktuellen Stellen. Und die Polarisierung des US-Wahlvolks. Ich habe die Situation seit dem amerikanischen Bürgerkrieg noch nie so ernst gesehen. Also die Polarisierung in die Systemstreite sind zurück seit 2016. Wir haben es mit einer grundlegenden Verfassungskrise zu tun und sich von den Ukrainen inspiriert zu sehen. Become a Sport wurde eine sportliche Herausforderung. Ich fand es ganz interessant, weil da wieder der Sport auftaucht, wie vorher schon. Und das ist so bei uns im Westen, fügt er nochmal an. Also diese Unterstützung der Ukraine. Gerade wenn wir, aber ich wollte wieder per DM nochmal so ein Hinweis gekriegt. Zelensky hat sich heute in so einem Symbol auf einem T-Shirt gezeigt. Irgend ein Raketending. Sehr viele Leute wissen, was es damit auf sich hat. Ich hatte es mir noch nicht genau angeguckt, aber es finden so Identifikationssachen gerade wieder statt, wo dann auch so Starbars-mäßige Hintergrundkulissen zum Denken einfach abgerufen werden. Und ja, wir kämpfen jetzt alle irgendwie gegen so ein Todessterben aus Russland. Und ja, das ist, es ist doch gruselig, ehrlich gesagt, sich mit so 30 Jahre alter Literatur. Fukuyama war damals 38 oder so, als er das geschrieben hat. Und ist jetzt so knapp 70, wird jetzt 70. Ja, das ist, also Fukuyama ist gerade einer der wichtigsten Autoren. Ich fand das sowieso immer auch, taucht er häufiger mal in Podcasts auf, Esra Klein und so. Ist aber wahnsinnig klug, ihm dazu zu hören.
Ich hab den Spott nie verstanden, der da ausgeschüttet wurde, auch von Linken. Zizek hat Fukuyama ja immer verteidigt in einer gewissen Weise. Zizek hat immer gesagt, bevor wir anfangen, Fukuyama zu kritisieren, sollten wir erst mal selbst überlegen, ob wir nicht wirklich Fukuyamaisten sind. Sind wir nicht selbst die, die eigentlich in dem Ende der Geschichte es uns behaglich gemacht haben und auch gar nicht mehr anerkennen wollen, wenn dann doch wieder die Geschichte beginnt in irgendeiner Weise? Und das ist genau das Richtige. Ich hab wenig Argumente gegen Fukuyama gefunden, viel Sport gegen Fukuyama. Und was ich nicht für möglich gehalten hätte, das ist jetzt aber auch so eine Einschätzung, dass es tatsächlich aus dieser Langeweile heraus wirklich noch mal, wo wir in einer solchen Komfortgesellschaft leben, in einer Gesellschaft, die sich schützt, die diese Slogans, wir bleiben zu Hause und all das hat, dass man tatsächlich bereit ist, jetzt überhaupt wieder diese Fragen des sich Opfens und so zu stellen, bei dem es immer nur darum geht, man selbst ist Menschen Material, das eingesetzt wird im Kriege von Leuten, die den Krieg lenken, die damit wenig zu tun haben, weil sie in warmen Polstern sitzen, und dass dazu noch mal Leute überhaupt bereit sind, also dass da nicht so viel Abstraktionsvermögen auch vorhanden ist, um zu sagen, also das würde ich auf keinen Fall machen, also dass ich mich für irgendwas noch einsetze, außer vielleicht noch für den ganz engen Radius der Familie, der Kinder, dass man sagt, für meine Kinder würde ich jetzt alles tun oder so, aber dass das noch mal darüber hinausgeht, das hätte ich nicht geglaubt, und dass es da fast so ein popkulturelles Abfeiern des Krieges gibt, das ist für mich ganz gespenstig und führt mich als zu einem enormen Fatalismus. Also das ist ja wirklich eine Frage, die man sich dann stellt, bei all den Dingen, die wir auch hier besprechen. Also dass alles, was wir hier besprechen, vom neuen Bauen bis hin zum Klimawandel oder was weiß ich, ist alles nur auf der Grundlage des Friedens möglich. Alles andere ist dann Makulatur, wenn der Frieden nicht da ist. Und dass das so wenig gesehen wird oder dass das so zusammengeht. Hier noch die Hafermilch und da aber schon das Anfeuern von Krieg, das man jubelt, wenn man junge Menschen sieht, die freiwillig dann aus dem Westen die Ukraine ziehen, um sich dann der Front zu opfern. Also, dass da jemand wirklich eine Begeisterung für aufbringen kann, ist mir vollkommen schleierhaft.
Ich habe die Tage ein philosophisches Radio mit dem Wiebecke gehört, das ich sehr gut fand. Da wurde nochmal dieses 100 Jahre alte Buch, Ich und du heißt es, glaube ich, besprochen.
Martin Buber.
Richtig. Ich bin bei sowas leider so schlecht. Ich habe das mir eine Stunde angehört. Aber naja, dieser Text wurde jedenfalls von einem Lehrer jetzt nochmal aktualisiert. Und da ist mir dann dieses Konzept untergekommen. Also ich habe noch nichts dazu gelesen, aber zumindest im Gespräch gehört und fand es irgendwie instruktiv, von Ich und du und Ich und es zu reden. Und damals in Redaktionsschluss habe ich ja mit Dirk Becker auch darüber gesprochen, dass Social Media, der Glaube, man hätte es, wenn man mit einem Computer, mit einem Gerät kommuniziert, auf der anderen Seite mit Menschen zu tun, wie sehr das in die Irre führt. Du hast jetzt gerade nochmal hervorgehoben, wie groß der Unterschied zwischen Krieg und Frieden ist. In Frieden ist alles möglich. Und im Krieg ist nichts mehr möglich außer der Krieg. Da geht es nur noch um Zerstörung. Mit allen Folgen, dass wir wissen, und das ist ja in der Ukraine auch schon ein Problem, ein Jahr Krieg bedeutet zehn Jahre Beseitigung von Minen und so weiter. Also der Krieg hängt einfach unglaublich lange nach. Und lässt dann auch kein Frieden zu. Also dieser Unterschied von Krieg und Frieden ist wahnsinnig groß. Und jetzt gerade wird mir wieder deutlich, wie gigantisch der Unterschied zwischen echter Kommunikation mit echten Menschen und eben Social Media ist. Und diese ganze Kriegsthematisierung, Verherrlichung, Kommentierung und so weiter und so fort, die findet, wenn wir ehrlich sind, alle nur computervermittelt statt. Man sitzt nicht in der Kneipe und redet ernsthaft über einen Krieg. Also ernsthaft im Sinne von, glaubt dann wirklich gerade über den Krieg so zu sprechen, dass man ihn noch mit verändert oder so. Sondern während man so über Krieg spricht, in einem echten Gespräch, merkt man relativ zügig, ja, wir reden hier über etwas, das ist ganz weit weg von uns. Wir können zwar hier darüber reden und wir können irgendwie noch mal reproduzieren, was wir vorher gelesen haben und so weiter, aber es macht alles keinen Unterschied. Während man bei Social Media immer glaubt, das macht jetzt gerade einen Unterschied. Man kommentiert irgendwelche Briefe, die irgendwer geschrieben hat, macht sich lustig darüber, dass es offene Briefe sind, überlegt sich, sollten die nicht mal geschlossene Briefe schreiben und solche Scherze. Aber diese Entkopplung von Realität, also wie weit man da nicht ich und du, sondern ich und es ist, sich mit Geräten, mit Maschinen auseinandersetzt, die keinen Unterschied machen, die einem einfach nur so ein Gefühl geben von, damit aber komplett betrügen. Also da liegt echter Betrug vor durch das Silicon Valley, das uns vorgaukelt, hier irgendwie wirksam zu sein oder so. Das wurde mir jetzt wieder deutlich, nachdem ich so punktuell nachlas, was auf Twitter diskutiert wird. Es ist wirklich gruselig.
Und vielleicht ist Martin Buber da eine ganz gute Adresse, denn die Idee ist ja auch einer solchen Philosophie, dass wo ich und du aufeinandertreffen, eine andere Form entstehen kann des Zusammenlebens, beziehungsweise etwas anderes nicht mehr denkbar ist. Also der Krieg funktioniert so, wie du ihn jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, oder wie er dann auch in die Tat umgesetzt wird, dass man das Du nicht als Ich auch mit erkennt. Also im Du das Ich auch sehen, sondern man sieht nicht mehr, dass Mensch gegen Mensch dort kämpft, dass ein Mensch den anderen tötet, sondern Krieg sieht dann so aus, dass man irgendetwas Diffuses, den Feind, den Todesstern, Sauron, besiegen muss und dann nicht mehr im Du, das Ich erkennt. Und das ist eigentlich das, was ein grundsätzlich unethisches in den Krieg hineinbringt. Und das ist es auch, was diese unglaubliche Dynamik los ist, weil gar kein Innehalten mehr ist, wo ich und du uns gegenüberstehen. Wo ich und du uns gegenüberstehen und uns streiten und zoffen und so, ist aber dann doch eine Anerkennung des anderen im Ich möglich und umgekehrt. Aber der Krieg lässt genau das nicht zu.
Mein Plädoyer ist Social Media nur noch dafür zu nutzen, Ich-Botschaften zu senden, wie unzufrieden, unglücklich und erschrocken man darüber ist, dass gerade ein Krieg läuft. Aber nicht mehr mit so einer Idee zu verbinden, dass man über den eigenen Klicktivismus, und das ist auch gleich Thema im Buch, irgendwas verändern kann. Also es gibt kein Handeln im Social Media, es gibt da nur Erleben. Und das muss man sich bewusst werden, sonst fällt man da wirklich mal auf die Nase.
Klicktivismus, das ist gut, dass du das ansprichst. Es kommt nur ganz, ganz wenig mal überhaupt Social Media vor. Das sind vielleicht fünf, sechs Stellen. Und dennoch ist das ja ein richtig gutes Buch über Social Media. Das ist das Erstaunliche, also dass sie jetzt nicht sagen, jetzt gehen wir da noch mal durch. Wie war das jetzt mit all dem? Also klar, da geht es mal kurz um Cambridge Analytica oder so, aber es ist jetzt wirklich kein Buch, das sagt, und jetzt reden wir über Silicon Valley, sondern es ist ein Buch darüber, in dem es das erste Mal umschifft. Und wenn wir jetzt mal bei Fukuyama bleiben, müssen wir noch mal einen Schritt zurückgehen zu Hegel, was da eigentlich mit gemeint ist. Also von Hegel gibt es diese Idee des Endes der Geschichte. Wir wissen, Hegel war ein großer Napoleon-Verehrer, hat Napoleon auch selbst gesehen, wie er dort zu Pferde ritt. Hegel sah dann, so schrieb er, die Weltseele zu Pferde, sah also, wie sich die Geschichte entwickelt, also auseinandergewickelt hat. Und damit war man an einem Ende nach der französischen Revolution. Das Ende der Geschichte bedeutet aber nicht, dass die Geschichte dann gänzlich zur Ruhe kommt. Also die Geschichte wird nicht in dem Sinne sediert und dann tut sich nichts mehr, sondern die Geschichte beginnt vom Neuen, aber wandert wieder auf das Ende zu. Ich will einen Abschnitt vorlesen, weil es erstmal sehr merkwürdig klingt. Die Freiheit war somit nicht nur eine abstrakte philosophische, sondern eine politische Aussage, die in konkreten Institutionen verwirklicht werden konnte. Dies war Hegels ursprüngliche Idee des Endes der Geschichte, dass alles, was auf die französische Revolution folgte, auf dem universellen Anspruch der menschlichen Freiheit beruhen musste. Dies wiederum bedeutete, keine soziale oder politische Ordnung könne jemals völlig stabil sein. Das Fundamentale dieser Einsicht liegt darin, dass die Freiheit nicht auf ein bestimmtes Regime oder eine bestimmte Ordnung beschränkt werden kann, da es gerade die Ausdehnung und Ruhelosigkeit der menschlichen Freiheit ist, die über ein bestimmtes System von politischen und sozialen Institutionen hinausgeht. Wenn wir das jetzt uns vergegenwärtigen, können wir sehr viele Strömungen politischer Natur einordnen, weil sie immer wieder zu irgendeiner Freiheit hin tendieren. Also zum Beispiel haben wir die Debatte jetzt in den USA und fast möchte man es nicht mehr Debatte nennen, denn es ist auch schon fast ein Krieg um das Thema Abtreibung, wo plötzlich die Freiheit der einen beschnitten wird, also derer, die für die Liberalisierung oder den Verbleib dieser Liberalisierung von Abtreibungsgesetzen sind. Während wir auf der anderen Seite religiöse, nennen wir sie ruhig Fundamentalisten haben, die sagen, unsere Freiheit wird beschnitten durch diese Liberalität und wir wollen unsere religiöse Freiheit da weiter ausweiten. Das heißt also, die Freiheiten, die da sind, werden also immer wieder neu definiert. Freiheit ist also deshalb für jede demokratische Bewegung ein fundamentaler Begriff, weil diese Freiheit, also die Tendenz des Menschen zur Freiheit, dass man nicht sich als Untertan einfach begreift, wie es vor der französischen Revolution üblich war. Das ist etwas, was also die Geschichte immer wieder in Gang setzt, aber zu ihrem Ende insofern führt, als diese wir schaffen eine Freiheit und dann ist Ruhe natürlich immer mitschwingt. Also dass man sagt, und dann ist gut, dann müssen wir nicht mehr kämpfen. Aber das bleibt natürlich und sie sagen dann auch, wir wissen, dass jedes Regime der Neuzeit, dass die menschliche Freiheit nicht in sein kollektives Leben integriert, begrenzt und partiell sein wird. Ein Satz, der mir eigentlich am meisten Hoffnung gegeben hat, denn natürlich ist auch ein Regime Putin nicht ewig, denn das ist gerade eines, das die Freiheit ganz erheblich beschneidet. Jetzt ist das noch nicht so totalitär, wie wir das aus dem 20. Jahrhundert unter Stalin oder so kennen, aber wir können da ganz klar beobachten, die Freiheit wird bekämpft, aber es ist auch in der russischen Bevölkerung der Drang der Freiheit da. Auch die französische Revolution wurde quasi auch von den Russen durchgemacht, wenn man so möchte. Und auch da wird sich das in eine Richtung entwickeln. Und ich glaube sogar auch in China, nur wahrscheinlich mit längerer Zeit oder so. Aber dieses grundsätzliche Subjekt, das hin zur Freiheit strebt, ist eines, das immer wieder hinstreben will zum Ende der Geschichte. Aber damit auch immer wieder das Ende des Endes bedeutet.
Ja, also jetzt hast du China angesprochen. Ich nutze das mal als Aufhänger für einen Punkt. Die kommen auf Hegel zu sprechen. Die französische Revolution hat den Menschen mit der Freiheitsidee infiziert. Egal an welchem Ort, egal in welchem Regime er später lebt. Die Geschichte ist geschrieben der französischen Revolution. Man kann sie nachlesen. Man kann die Idee von Freiheit entwickeln. Das wiederholt sich mit dem Mauerfall. Die Bürger sagen ihren Politikern, Herr Kennedy, ich will nicht wissen, was ich für mein Land tun kann. Ich will jetzt Wohlstand. Die Idee von Freiheit war schon Jahrhunderte gesetzt. Die Idee des Wohlstands kommt dann noch dazu. Die wurde ja den Ostdeutschen richtig reingeimpft. Du kriegst Begrüßungsgeld und kannst natürlich Karriere machen. Es sind erst mal drei Millionen junge Frauen rüber und haben in Bayern, Baden-Württemberg und Nordrhein-Westfalen Wohlstandskarriere gemacht. Von den natürlich auch die Zurückgebliebenen so. Ah ja, so kann man also auch leben. Wohlstand ist jetzt sozusagen das Ziel. Und jetzt haben wir bei Sendel schon gelesen, wie sehr dieses Bildungsversprechen, jeder kann am Wohlstand teilnehmen, man muss sich ordentlich anstrengen und so weiter. Und die Irre führt, dieses ganze Leistungsprinzip. Und jetzt an China sehen wir ja wieder, dass da Tauschgeschäfte stattfinden, dass die Menschen wirklich einverstanden sind damit. Ich lasse mir meine Freiheit gerne nehmen, wenn ich damit das Versprechen bekomme, in die Mittelschicht aufzusteigen. Genau das ist ja das Programm von Qi gerade, dass er da fährt. So, und jetzt hast du also das sozusagen Wohlstand in China. Und jetzt hast du die Abtreibungsdebatten, die ja nun wirklich gerade mega heikel werden in Amerika, wenn jetzt dieses 50 Jahre alte Gesetz, das Frauen allein über wie soll man sagen Privatsphäre ein Recht auf Abtreibung zugestellt, gekippt wird und dann 26 Bundesstaaten bereitstehen und sagen Ja, wir haben ja schon Gesetze, die jegliche Abtreibung verbieten, selbst im Fall der Vergewaltigung oder sonstiges, dass wir hier auch wieder mit krassen Freiheitseinschränkungen zu tun haben. Ich würde nicht mal so sehr sagen, dass diejenigen, die das befürworten, selbst Freiheitsverteidiger sind, also dass sie sagen, so ich will meine Freiheit, nämlich dass Gott hier einfach walten darf, wie er will. Und wenn er da ein Kind hinwirft, dann muss das gerne gedeihen. Ich würde nicht mal sagen, dass das unter Freiheit läuft, sondern dass einfach Freiheit hier wirklich in Gefahr ist. Egal aus welcher Richtung. So und die Frage, die sich ja echt so ein bisschen stellt, können wir mit Wohlstand alleine, aber dann ohne Freiheit, also so wie in Amerika oder dann eben jetzt in China und so weiter, ist das ein Modell? Und da muss man echt sagen, nee, das würde nicht reichen. Menschen brauchen irgendwie auch Freiheit, aber sie kommt gerade wirklich unter die Räder. Und irgendwo da in dieser Gemengelage, und deswegen ist mir das auch ein bisschen unklar in dem Buch, irgendwo da ist ja dieses Ende des Endes der Geschichte. Also wo die großen Kämpfe, die großen Systemstreite, da wo man auch wirklich mal was opfert, wo man zum Beispiel sagt, ich bin bereit, wurscht dann zu opfern, wenn wir nur wieder auch für Freiheit kämpfen können. Irgendwo da scheint ja dieser Wunsch zu sein, dass jetzt ein Ende des Endes der Geschichte aufblitzt.
Aber ist das Ende des Endes nicht in gewisser Weise viel kleiner? Wir denken jetzt natürlich gleich wieder an so etwas wie einen neuen kalten Krieg und dann beginnt die Geschichte von neuem. Und sie kritisieren ja ein bisschen auch Fukuyama, dass er selbst seine eigenen These nicht vertraut hat über die Jahre hinweg, sondern das dann immer modifiziert hat und versucht hat, ein bisschen abzumildern. Aber eigentlich ist dieser ursprüngliche Aufsatz, der, glaube ich, gar nicht ins Deutsche übersetzt ist, also ich habe den zumindest immer nur im Englischen gelesen, dass dieser 20-, 25-seitige Aufsatz das eigentlich Entscheidende ist, wo er es formuliert. Und wenn wir jetzt uns mal überlegen, was wäre denn so ein Ende des Endes der Geschichte, dann geht es ja eigentlich darum, dass wieder sich irgendetwas in Gang setzt, was aber auch nicht unüblich ist für ein Ende der Geschichte im Sinne von Hegel. Der Mensch ist jetzt an dem Punkt angelangt, wo er immer nach Freiheit streben wird. Und da bringen sie meines Erachtens ein sehr, sehr gutes Zitat des das verdeutlicht. Das wurde mir auch noch nie so klar. Sijek schreibt da, Politik und Demokratie sind synonym zu verstehen. Und man denkt, wie ja, und dann sagen die Autoren aber schon vorher, naja, wir können jetzt über Sozialismus, Faschismus, Konservatismus und sowas reden. Und was eint die dann? Die versuchen jetzt hier keine Hufeisen zu schmieden, sondern die versuchen zu sagen, naja, diese Konzepte wollen eigentlich auf ein Ende der Geschichte hinaus. Und das bedeutet, sie wollen einen Raum schaffen ohne Politik. Also sie wollen die Politik enden lassen. Jetzt ist mal Schluss mit Politik. Jetzt haben wir hier einen paradiesischen Zustand erreicht oder eine Ständegesellschaft erreicht. Und mit der sollen wir uns jetzt zufrieden geben. Zizek sagte aber, dass das eben gerade etwas anderes bedeutet. Politik und Demokratie. Also das ist quasi ein Ziel, das eigentlich dann sagt, jetzt gibt es keine Politik mehr. Bei der Demokratie hat man aber ständig Politik. Und wie heißt es? Dies zeigt Zizek am Beispiel der antidemokratischen Politik, die, Zitat, immer und per Definitionen Endpolitisierung ist und war. Das heißt, die unbedingte Forderung, dass die Dinge zur Normalität zurückkehren sollen, wobei jeder einzelne seine spezielle Aufgabe erfüllt. Und Demokratie bedeutet aber, dass es diese Rückkehr nicht geben kann und dass es auch nicht diese Ruhe geben kann. Also, dass man eigentlich in so einem permanenten Kampf wieder ist. Der kann mal mehr oder weniger zur Ruhe kommen. Und das hat er getan in den 90er Jahren. Aber jetzt tauchen wieder andere Kämpfe auf. Und was sehr, glaube ich, entscheidend ist für die Rückkehr der Politik, ist ja nicht der Systemwettstreit in erster Linie, sondern erst einmal bleiben sie ja vorwiegend in westlichen Gefilden. Und sagen, die Antipolitik, die bringt jetzt eigentlich wieder die Geschichte in Gang. Beziehungsweise jetzt fängt die Demokratie wieder an zu arbeiten, zu erwachen.
Also, die Politik ist Demokratie. Ich habe mir da so drunter notiert, unter diesem T-Sex-Spruch. Ja, das sagt Luhmann auch. Funktionale Differenzierung heißt, wir haben es mit einer Professionalisierung von Politik zu tun, in diesem Sinne, dass die Kritik an der Politik selbst schon in der Politik stattfindet. Und nicht irgendwo sonst, in der Wirtschaft, in der Wissenschaft oder so, sondern wer politische Kritik üben will, geht einfach ins Parlament und gehört dort zur Opposition. Luhmann übertreibt es dann soweit, dass er sogar ein Parteien-Systeme dieser Art der Ausdifferenzierung von Politik zutraut, wie wir es beispielsweise in China sehen, wenn nur der politische Kampf zwischen Regierung und, sagen wir mal, trotzdem Opposition dazu so stattfindet, dass er in die Bevölkerung, ins Wahlvolk hineingetragen wird, dort sich dann Mehrheiten zusammenfinden, die man wie auch immer demoskopisch abfangen kann. Und das sehen wir ja auch in China zum Beispiel. Also der Qi zwingt ja nicht den Chinesen irgendetwas auf. Klar, da findet auch Nudging und Propaganda statt, auch in erheblichem Maße. Aber am Ende ist es trotzdem wichtig, dass sie, und es kann dann auch Inception sein, einen Volkswillen aufgreifen.
Das ist der Begriff der Massenlinie, auf den er sich ja bezieht. Das ist ja ein Begriff, den Mao geprägt hat. Also wir und die Funktionäre, wir gehen. Und erfahren den Volkswillen und setzen ihn um. Natürlich bedeutet das auch eine Manipulation des Volkswillens, aber es ist nicht losgelöst davon. Also das ist nicht einfach, ich hole die Peitsche raus und alle sollen gehorchen. Das würde auch nicht funktionieren.
Genau. Die Mobilisierung läuft über Bande. Und zwar nicht, sie kann nicht ausschließlich über Gewalt laufen. Das sehen wir im Krieg. Das wäre dann auch sozusagen ein Bürgerkrieg der Regierung oder der Mächtigen gegen die Unmächtigen, dass sie es immer nur über Zwang machen, sondern nein, wir haben es in China durchaus mit intrinsischen Motivationen, Qi zu stützen, zu tun, auch wenn das seinerseits wieder auf Manipulation beruht.
Und da könnte sein, dass das jetzt zu weit treibt. Vielleicht sprechen wir in der nächsten Folge noch mal darüber gesondert, wenn man sich diese Siro-Covid-Strategie anzieht, die jetzt an einen Punkt angelangt ist, wo es nicht mehr um irgendwelche Freiheiten oder ich höre mal, was wollen die eigentlich, sondern das ist jetzt reine Repression. Und noch nie war es eigentlich in der Amtszeit von Xi so heikel, weil man gar nicht mehr weiß, wie viel Wut ist da schon in der Bevölkerung da, dass sie sich nicht knechten lassen wollen. Denn auch das Wohlschanzversprechen wird ja so nicht eingelöst, wenn alle eingesperrt werden und nichts gekauft werden kann.
Genau, genau. Da wird weder was produziert, noch was konsumiert. Und damit wird es dann wirklich heikel. Und dann muss man auch sagen, du hast jetzt Repression genannt. Genau. Dann ist es nicht mehr Politik, sondern dann ist es Gewaltherrschaft. So. Und in diesem Buch ist mir völlig unklar, vielleicht habe ich es auch nicht konzentriert genug gelesen, ich bin mir diesmal wirklich unsicher. Die reden natürlich auch über den Brexit. Und die Brexit-Histerie. So. Die wir ja auch mitgetragen haben. Also die Entscheidung für den Brexit war einfach irrational und dumm. Das kann man einfach, wenn man so einen Schlussstrich darunter zieht, das ist jetzt auch schon sechs Jahre her fast, dass diese Entscheidung fiel, das zu machen. Und wir haben seitdem gesehen, wie sie es inhaltlich entfaltet hat. Die allerdings, die drei Autoren, kommen ja auf den Brexit durchaus zu sprechen mit, das war einer der Versuche, die Geschichte wieder zum Laufen zu bringen. Die gängige Idee, die gerade politisch durchgesetzt und fortentwickelt wird, nicht einfach nur mit Defizitkritik im Sinne von, naja, die EU-Mitgliedschaft muss so ein bisschen verbessert werden oder die Engländer brauchen da noch mehr Zugeständnis oder wie auch immer, aber wir rütteln nicht an der EU-Mitgliedschaft, sondern dass da einfach gesagt wurde, ne, wir wollen jetzt gar keine EU-Mitgliedschaft mehr, wir wollen ein anderes System. Dann haben sich die Briten natürlich so ein bisschen verstrickt in irgendwas, weiß ich, Global Britain und so, wie man es dann immer aufgedröselt hat, oder das Commonwealth nochmal zu restaurieren, was auch immer. Aber ich glaube, die Autoren sahen da so ein Potential drin und die nahmen es ja auch Korbin nicht übel, sich nie zum Brexit verhalten zu haben. Jedenfalls nicht abfällig oder dagegen argumentieren, sondern dass er das auch mitgetragen hat.
Also wo stehen die Autoren politisch? Ich habe das jetzt nicht in irgendeiner Weise nachvollzogen, sondern habe nur Textexegese betrieben. Und ich kenne auch den Podcast nicht, aber natürlich sind die eher dem radikal linken Lager angehörig und haben erst einmal Sympathien dafür, wenn man versucht, den herrschenden Konsens in Frage zu stellen und auch den linksliberalen Konsens. Und ich glaube, das wird an einer Stelle besonders deutlich, wo es auch um den Brexit geht. Und zwar heißt es da im dritten Kapitel, die Endpolitisierung ist in der Tat eine politische Strategie, die auf der Ebene der Institutionen und Prozesse stattfindet. Die Praxis des Regierens wurde vom Druck der Masse isoliert. Das klassische Beispiel ist die Unabhängigkeit der Zentralbanken, die die Geldpolitik aus dem Bereich der Politik entführte. Wir wissen ja um das Demokratiedefizit generell bei der EU. Wir waren ja dann immer mal wieder in diesem Podcast auch schon bereit, dieses Demokratiedefizit hinzunehmen, weil wir sagten, um Gottes Willen, was wäre, wenn wirklich die CDU damit reinfunken könnte und Herr Gauweiler aus Karlsruhe noch Rabatz schlägt. Was ist dann eigentlich? Also dann ist man froh um diese Unabhängigkeit. Das macht uns ein bisschen auch, Stefan. Da hast du schon recht zu Technokraten, die hier kritisiert werden. Andererseits habe ich dann das Interview mit Isabel Schnabel gesehen und dachte, okay, die wissen uns aber auch nicht so richtig in der Zentralbank. Also vielleicht brauchen wir doch eine Demokratisierung. Naja, das war also natürlich schon eine Entscheidung für das Reich des kleineren Übels, die wir da vorgenommen haben. Aber das ist erstmal das, was sie hier feststellen. Und das ist auch so, dass man sagt, naja, es gibt da diese Black Box EU. So hieß mal ein Text aus den Blättern. Aber naja, so ist es dann eben. Und jetzt kommt es aber. Jede in Fragestellung dieser Ordnung wird als wütender Rückfall behandelt, der von irrationalen Wünschen getriebenen Unzufriedenen zugeschrieben wird. Im Extremfall werden diese als machohaft, frauenfeindlich, homophob oder rassistisch eingestuft. Die ultimativen Verbrechen gegen eine pluralistische, konsensorientierte Politik, ob wahr oder nicht. Das ist ganz interessant. Gestern schrieb mir ein Freund, nachdem es ja diese Anhörung gab von dem Amazon-Gewerkschafter Smalls, was glaubst du, wann irgendwie die Liberalen so einen Skandal um ihn ausmachen können, dass er mal irgendwo was gesagt hat, gemacht hat oder so. Man wartet eigentlich nur darauf, damit sie ihn dann abservieren können, damit er doch nicht seine politisch tollen Forderungen durchsetzen kann. Und dann heißt es hier, der Brexit-Slogan Take Back Control wurde als bloßer Deckmantel für Fremdenfeindlichkeit abgetan, womit das Demokratiedefizit, auf das er abzielte, ignoriert wurde. Die Anhänger von Bernie Sanders wurden als Kumpel Bros. verspottet, als ob die von ihm vertretene Umverteilungspolitik nur für junge weiße Männer von Interesse sein könnte. Durch Verleumdung wird jede Forderung des Volkes als illegitim behandelt und die offizielle Politik hört auf, ein Weg für echte politische Auseinandersetzung zu sein. Und das fand ich zum Beispiel, konnte man bei der Wahl in Frankreich jetzt gut beobachten. Da hat dann Katharina Barley vor der ersten Wahl, also als noch alles möglich war, schon ermahnt die Leute, dass Macron gewählt werden muss und nicht so jemand wie Mélenchon. Denn dann wäre ja alles schon verloren. Und man hat also versucht, immer wieder eine Politik, jenseits von Macron, eine Linke, als unrealistisch, naiv, kindisch, vielleicht auch populistisch oder so abzutun. Natürlich sind diese anderen Politiker die Zentristen, wenn man so möchte, auch alle populisten in ihrer Art und Weise. Aber das sind die guten Populisten. Und dass man also diese Alternative, am besten noch durch irgendeinen Skandal hier, der hat man das und das bei Facebook vor sieben Jahren geschrieben, dass man sie damit aus dem Diskurs rausdrängt, das ist, glaube ich, schon was, was wir laufend erleben. Und deswegen ist das zwar kein Plädoyer für den Brexit von den Autoren, aber sie zeigen doch auf, dass sich in diesem Abstimmungsverhalten etwas tiefergehendes zeigt, dass nicht einfach damit zu erklären ist, naja, das sind halt einfach Hinterweltler. Auch wenn es dumm ist, für den Brexit zu sein.
Ja, genau. Es steckt so eine Faszination für Populismus drin. Sie wird mit dem Begriff ja auch ein Kapitel und fragen dann gleichzeitig, nur weil die, die gerade regieren, anderen vorwerfen, sie seien Populisten, sind sie denn deswegen keine Populisten? Wir haben dieses Adam Toos Buch gelesen, wie Menschen im Homeoffice ohne weitere, also demokratische Beauftragung, ja, aber Legitimierung so ein bisschen fadenscheinig, einfach 14 Billionen Dollar locker gemacht haben. So, jede Demokratisierung dieses Verfahrens hätte es verzögert und damit den Erfolg genommen. So, das muss man einfach so sagen. Und da ist so ein interessantes Einfallstor, dass die Autoren grundsätzlich erstmal jede Art von Populismus wohlwollend aufgreifen, weil sie vermuten, dass darin wieder die Anstachelung zu einem großen Systemstreit drin stecken könnte. Sei es die Trump-Wahl, sei es der Brexit. Hauptsache Debatte. Debatte first irgendwie. Erstmal wieder die Geschichte zum Laufen bringen. Wieder echte, und das muss man ja echt sagen, Anerkennungstriebfedern schaffen, für die Leute bereit sind, wirklich was zu opfern. Wir sind ja immer wieder fasziniert. Der Wendler, Xavier Naidoo und so weiter, wie sehr die ihre ganze wirtschaftliche Grundlage einfach geopfert haben, um irgendeine Ideologie auszubreiten. Das können wir ja gar nicht glauben, wie nicht duckmäuserisch das ist, sondern dass sie einfach wirklich Opfer gezeigt haben. Kann man auch wieder sagen, es ist dumm und so weiter, und es stimmt ja irgendwie auch. Aber es fand halt trotzdem so statt. Und für diese Art des sich politisch Zeigens haben die hier große Sympathien.
Aber ich hoffe, sie würden nicht so weit gehen, dass sie jetzt alles, was irgendwie stattfindet, als großartig als wahrnehmen, also wo immer irgendwo aufgemuckt wird. Denn das sind ja oft einfach nur solche Unmutbekundungen, die wirklich bloßes Ausagieren sind, die aber dann zu überhaupt nichts Sinnvollem führen. Aber was sie doch sehr schön aufzeigen können, ist, wie eigentlich so ein linksliberaler Konsens es auch immer wieder schafft, wirklich sinnvolle, radikale Positionen wie zum Beispiel die von Bernie Sanders als nicht legitim dastehen zu lassen. Und ich finde, es ist ein Buch, das wirklich sehr polemisch manchmal ist, schafft, das zuzuspitzen, aber sehr differenziert in der Analyse ist und uns sehr gut aufzeigen kann, was haben wir denn eigentlich jetzt gerade für ein Koordinatensystem. Denn das ist ja auch so, dass das in einer Form immer wieder als Tabelle auch erscheint. Also das ist ja auch, dass wir mehrmals Tabellen in diesem Buch haben und dann gesagt wird, wo stehen wir eigentlich da heute? Also das Ende des Endes der Geschichte beginnt 2016 und geht jetzt so weiter.
Und meint er aber zum Beispiel nicht nur Trump, sondern auch Corbyn, auch Sanders, Brexit natürlich. Also nicht nur Trump und Brexit, sondern darüber hinaus.
Ja. Und da sagen sie erst mal so, die hegemoniale politische Kraft ist Antipolitik. Antipolitik, das meint und deswegen, weil sie den Bunga Bunga Podcast machen, wissen sie das so gut, eigentlich schon das, was Berlusconi verspricht. Es gibt eine generelle Tendenz, sagen sie in der populistischen Politik, gegen Korruption zu sein. Jetzt denkt man ja erst einmal, na ja, ist ja auch gut, wir haben uns ja selber jetzt aufgeregt über die ganzen Korruptionsfälle in Deutschland in den vergangenen Jahren. Und dann sagen sie, ja, das mag zwar alles stimmen und es gibt auch Korruption und die hat zugenommen, auch dadurch, dass es so viel Privatisierung gibt. Da hat man also erst einmal gute Möglichkeiten zu Korruption geschaffen. Aber mit dieser Antikorruptionspolitik ist oft Folgendes verbunden. Man will die Politik reinigen. Man will sagen, da ist die komische korrupte Elite und von der müssen wir die Welt oder zumindest unser Land befreien. Und dieser Gestus ist erst einmal etwas, der überall ankommt. Also weil alle ja auch so ein diffuses Gefühl haben. Die sind aber auch korrupt. Und ja, Korruption ist ja auch ein großes Problem, wenn man sich so Korruptionsindizes ansieht. Nur die Sache ist, diese Politik führt nicht dazu, dass man eigentlich noch zu einer, zu einem institutionellen, wieder funktionierenden politischen Prozess kommt. Sondern man ist dann in diesem Modus der Antipolitik. Das ist ja das, was sie dokumentieren. Die ist hegemonial. Und da heißt es, die Antipolitik kann von unten oder von oben kommen. Als organisatorische Entwicklung innerhalb der Massen oder von oben von bestehenden politischen Vertretern oder neuen Gegeneliten. Die Antipolitik, die sich gegen den Konsens der Manager richtet, scheint zu politisieren. Wenn Populisten einen Antagonisten zwischen Volk und Eliten behaupten und versprechen, den Sumpf trocken zu legen, ist das eine elementare Politisierung, denn sie fordert Spaltung statt Konsensstörung statt Business as usual. Die Antipolitik zielt aber auch auf die politische Autorität selbst, auf die Möglichkeit der Repräsentation überhaupt. Diese Unfähigkeit, jeder denkbaren Macht Legitimität zu verleihen, ist wahrhaft antipolitisch und verheerend, nicht nur für die liberale Demokratie, sondern auch für die radikaldemokratischen Bewegungen. Das ist also auch eine ganz klare Kritik an diesen ganzen populistischen, auch linkspopulistischen Strömungen, dass die zwar in ihrem Eifer in gewisser Weise einen Punkt haben, den aber dann auch irgendwann so weit treiben, dass sie sagen, naja, also generell wollen wir nicht mehr von irgendwas repräsentiert werden. Wir selbst sind ja die Stimme, die stattfinden soll. Und dann fragt man sich aber, wie soll das politisch organisiert werden? Also eigentlich, auch wenn der hier nie erwähnt wird, ist es auch ein Luhmann-Buch, würde ich sagen. Also das ist schon auch ein ganz klares Plädoyer für Organisationen, Institutionen und so Sachen. Nur vielleicht dann in anderer Weise demokratisch legitimiert. Aber es ist nicht ein Buch, das sagt, wir müssen jetzt einfach nur so eine radikale Intervention hinbekommen, irgendein Movement. Sondern da sagen sie ja, das ist verheerend für die liberale Demokratie. Während also die Antipolitik anfänglich politisiert, wirkt sie gleichzeitig die Gefahr der Abschaffung jeglicher Politik, ob von oben oder von unten. Das macht den Weg frei für autoritäre Herrschaft. Und das können wir ja wirklich perfekt an Trump sehen. Das haben wir am besten vor Augen, dass Trump sagt, ich will diesen Sumpf da austrocknen in Washington und diese ganzen linksliberalen Eliten, Hollywood-Eliten und so weiter. Und in gewisser Weise hat er sogar einen Punkt, wenn wir uns ansehen, wie korrupt das ist. Wir haben das ja auch in diesem Amazon-Buch nachgelesen, was da in Washington so passiert. Und dann ist das aber soweit, dass eigentlich die Repräsentation selbst nicht mehr statthaft ist. Alles wird dann abgeräumt. Und dann kommt man eigentlich nur noch dahin, dass man sagen muss, gut, dann kann ich das nur noch als autoritäre Herrschaft verstehen. Und das erklärt vielleicht ein bisschen auch diese Radikalisierung von Trump, auf die du ja auch immer wieder hinweist. Trump ist nicht so ins Amt gekommen, wie er rausgegangen ist. Dass man dann, wenn man in diesem Furore weitermacht, eigentlich nur noch kommt so, jetzt bin ich der Präsident, jetzt regiere ich. Und am Ende lasse ich auch auf Demonstranten schießen, wenn es sein muss.
Genau. Du hast es jetzt als Luhmann-Buch. Das stimmt. In deutscher Sprache hätte man viel davon einarbeiten können. Ich versuche es mal so aus Lesersicht einfach nachzuarbeiten. Diese Anti-Korruptionspolitik. Also da kommt jemand wie Trump und sagt, ich ziehe jetzt nach Washington und lege dort mal den Sumpf trocken. Ich kämpfe auch gegen den Deep State und so weiter. Führt, sagen sie, zur Anti-Politik oder Autokratie. Und als Beispiel haben sie dann Grillo, Trump, Bolsonaro, alles Leute, die sozusagen aus dem Volk, vom Lande, nicht aus der Akademiker-Urban-Schicht, Erwan, genau, die sich da einfach Repräsentanten des einfachen Mitbürgers politisch durchsetzen. Und damit heben sie, da könnte man jetzt Lumans Legitimation durch Verfahren einfach auf und sagen, Legitimation durch Person. Wir müssen als Wähler, wenn wir das wollen, diese Art der Anti-Korruptionspolitik, das ist ja ein sehr vulgärer Konzept so, aber wenn wir wollen, dass da jemand mit starker Faust einfach in die Hauptstadt ein reitet und dort einfach mal aufräumt, dann bedeutet das, wir müssen uns komplett in diese Person investieren. So und während wir dieses Amazon-Buch lesen und dort feststellen, ja der Jeff Bezos, dem kostet das ganz schön viel Geld in die Institutionen, die da sind, sich einzukaufen, stellen wir eben bei Trump fest. Und das ist ja auch eine der großen Frank Underwood-Lehren gleich aus den ersten Folgen. Es gibt eben Macht und Macht. Man kann sich in Washington einkaufen für sehr viel Geld, dann hat man so Macht. Oder man wird Politiker und dann hat man echte Macht. Weil dann kann man die Institutionen einfach abräumen. Allein über populistischen Furore, wie du das gerade genannt hast. Das ist einfach, 51 Prozent der Leute sagen, genau das will ich. Und es haben eben auch 49 Prozent der unter 40-jährigen Franzosen jetzt gesagt, ich will depend. Also wir sind ja auch kurz vor so einer Schwelle, wo auch in Frankreich einfach dieser populistische Furore über Antipolitik und dieses ganze Verwaltung und Struktur und Institution funktioniert nicht. Wir brauchen jetzt mal eine Person und die schicken wir dahin. Und der vertrauen wir aber auch voll und ganz. Und wenn die uns sagt, die hat ein ganz tolles Telefonat mit Zelensky geführt, obwohl da eigentlich Betrug und Erpressung stattfand, dann sagen wir einfach, na, liest doch selber das Transkript. So, ja, mach dir doch, mach, do your own research und so weiter. Ich will ja gar nicht in, ich bin, also ich vertraue dieser Person, ich lass mich davon nicht abbringen. So, und dann kommen sie auf Berlusconi, so ein bisschen genauer zu sprechen, weil der eben dieses Ende der Geschichte total ausgenutzt hat damals. Italien war fast ein sozialistischer Staat, 89, und hat dann ganz abrupt diese EU-Regeln aufgedrückt bekommen. Was für Berlusconi bedeutete, geil, hier wird alles privatisiert, ich kauf den ganzen Mediensektor auf. Dann hat er 20 Jahre Zeit gehabt, diesen Mediensektor einmal, der vorher schon Staatsfernsehen war, sozusagen auf Personenfernsehen zu trimmen, sich als Person wirklich als Alternative zu den Institutionen hinzustellen. Und dann mit diesem Motto, ich durfte und jetzt dürft ihr auch. Wählt mich einfach, ihr dürft. So wie Obama sagte, yes we can, sagt Berlusconi einfach den Italienern, ihr dürft, ihr dürft auch. Nach meinem Vorbild. Und dann gab es diese große Verbrüderung sozusagen, dass dann auch Berlusconi eben mehr als eine Amtszeit und so weiter. Das war ja auch für Italien total unüblich. Da war ja immer nur Wechsel, Wechsel, Wechsel, alle halbe Jahre neue Wahl, irgendwie 60 Nachkriegsregierungen, 40 Jahre und so. Und dann kam plötzlich Berlusconi und hat sich da auch richtig einzementiert und hat sozusagen dieses Ende der Geschichte in Italien mal richtig ausgenutzt. Und zwischen diesen Kapiteln, also zwischen diesem Aufwerfen, Kapitel 5 der Anti-Korruptionspolitik und dann eben später diesen Kapitel über Italien, steht eben, ja was haben die Linken eigentlich dagegen geunternommen? Wie sieht Protest aus? Naja, man hat sich eben hingestellt und gesagt, wir sind unzufrieden mit der Sachlage, aber wir verbrüdern uns hier gar nicht und wir suchen uns auch keine Person aus, die uns repräsentiert, sondern wir machen Protest ganz ohne Repräsentation. Wir stehen auf der Straße, schreien rum, sind unzufrieden, rohe Empörung. Die Autoren wünschen sich ja dann auch gewerkschaftliche Militanz. Nichts davon ist mehr da. Und man hatte niemandem auch nur irgendwas entgegenzusetzen und sucht stattdessen immer nur das Haar in der Suppe, um dann doch nochmal, ja, als nächstes sind dann wirklich die Amazon-Gewerkschafter wahrscheinlich dran, um da einfach jeden nochmal abzuschießen, während auf der anderen Seite eben die Republikaner wirklich nur entscheiden, ja, wählen wir jetzt eigentlich Trump oder Dezentes beim nächsten Mal. Ja, so und mehr ist da gar nicht an Debatte, sondern ist einfach nur, indem wir den einen super Populisten oder den einen, der es ihm nochmal richtig zeigen will, wie es richtig geht, der Trump nachmacht, aber eben auch Ahnung hat, wie man dann Politik wirklich organisiert. So und dieser gefährliche Widersatz, das ist wirklich, das wurde dann in dem Buch auch nochmal richtig deutlich eigentlich.
Und sehr schön rausgearbeitet, auch gerade so ein paar Sätze dann nochmal zu Berlusconi, die man da liest. Berlusconi und auch die Parteifunktionäre, die anderen, haben Berlusconi nicht als einen Vorsitzenden der Partei angesehen, sondern als einen Chef. Und als Chef eines Unternehmens ist man ja quasi ein kleiner Diktator. Also man hat ja keine politische Legitimation. Vielleicht muss man ein bisschen die Macht auch abgeben, wenn man Betriebsrat oder so im Haus hat. Natürlich nicht im Unternehmen Berlusconi. Und er ist der Chef. Er entscheidet, wie das Ganze läuft. Die anderen sind so eine Fußtruppe, die da mitlaufen, einfach um eine gewisse Massendynamik herzustellen. Und wenn man eigentlich die Partei als Unternehmen begreift, und das ist das, was Berlusconi gemacht hat, und was Trump ja auch für die Republikaner vorschwebt, da hat es Trump ein bisschen schwerer, weil die republikanische Tradition etwas andere ist, als bei so einer Retorten-Partei, wie sie Berlusconi aufgebaut hat. Aber beides führt eigentlich in eine Richtung, dass man extrem machtbewusst agiert, extrem kalkuliert arbeitet, und dass man sehr genau weiß, welche Hebel der Manipulation man bedienen muss. Und um das noch mal, was du jetzt gerade schon angesprochen hast, zuzuspitzen, sie schreiben ja dann später noch mal sehr dezidiert über die Linken. Und sie greifen da auch den Intersektionalismus raus, der ja in linken Kreisen, und damit meine ich ja jetzt nicht kleine Seminarräume, sondern wirklich so in linksliberalen Kreisen mit, von der Funk-Sendung bis hin zum Spotify-Podcast dann vertreten ist. Da sagen sie einfach, Intersektionalität, ursprünglich ein Versuch verschiedener, aber ineinander greifende Form der Unterdrückung zusammenzufassen, ist zum vielleicht prominentesten Ausdruck eines als Politik getarnten, öffentlichen Narzissmus geworden. Sie hat die Frage, was wollen wir erreichen, aufgegeben zugunsten der Frage, wer bin ich? Statt zu fragen, wohin gehen wir, schreckt sie vor der Zukunft zurück und fragt sich, woher komme ich? Diese Form der Nabelschau traf schließlich auf ihren bösen Zwilling, in Form der Identitätspolitik der Rechten, doch beide hatten die gleiche Nabelschnur. Als sich die Identitätspolitik ihren Weg von den Universitäten zu den Mainstream-Medien, den Marketing-Abteilungen der Unternehmen und den internationalen Institutionen bahnte, wurde sie eher zu einer hegemonialen Kraft als zu einer radikalen Herausforderung. Und das können wir bei diesem ganzen politischen jetzt das Unternehmen so an den Tag legen, wunderbar erleben. Und das ist quasi dann auch die hegemonial gewordene Öffentlichkeit, die jetzt nur darauf wartet oder was sich ausdenkt, warum dann zum Beispiel eigentlich diese Amazon-Gewerkschafter doch gar nicht so gut sind, weil die eigentlich nicht so fortschrittlich oder wie die es gerne ausdrücken, progressiv sind. Und was ja dann noch mal als interessanter Punkt hineinkommt, als eine neue Klasse, ist ja das, was das Ehepaar Ehrenreich in den siebziger Jahren schon formuliert hat, nämlich diese Professional Managerial Class. Was ist denn das eigentlich? Ja, das sind so etwa 15 Prozent der Bevölkerung, sagt man, vielleicht auch etwas mehr. Das sind Leute, die sehr viel oder die sehr gutes Geld verdienen, aber nicht in der Form, dass sie Unternehmer sind, sondern sie sind in irgendeiner Weise angestellt. Und zwar heißt es da, oft waren sie in großen Unternehmen und Organisationen beschäftigt, wie die Arbeiterklasse. Aber sie waren als Manager, Akademiker, Lehrer, Verwaltungsangestellte, technische Angestellte, Kulturproduzenten, Ärzte, Rechtsanwälte und so weiter tätig. Sie unterschieden sich also funktional von den Arbeitern. Das wird also in den siebziger Jahren schon so diagnostiziert. Wie die Ehrenreichs es ausdrückten, handelte es sich dabei um angestellte geistige Arbeiter, die nicht im Besitz der Produktionsmittel sind und deren Hauptfunktion in der gesellschaftlichen Arbeitsteilung allgemein als die Reproduktion der kapitalistischen Kultur und der kapitalistischen Klassenbeziehung beschrieben werden kann. Die PMC ist also keine Klasse im eigentlichen Sinne. Sie hat weder ein strukturell antagonistisches Verhältnis zu Kapital oder Arbeit, noch ist sie ein Überbleibsel wie das Kleinbürgertum. Kleineigentümer, von denen viele in der frühen Phase der kapitalistischen Entwicklung ausgelöscht wurden. Sie, also die PMC, die Professional Managerial Class, ist ein Produkt des Monopolkapitalismus. Und diese PMC ist es also auch, die hegemonial geworden ist im westlichen politischen Diskurs, wenn es dann um Identitätspolitik und all das geht, die sich unglaublich empören kann. Zum Beispiel dann, wenn eine Marine Le Pen was sagt, aber auch wenn ein Bernie Sanders irgendwas macht. Und die dann aber nicht auf Seiten der Arbeiterklasse steht, sondern eigentlich doch immer als Repräsentant des Monopolkapitalismus die herrschende Ordnung strukturiert oder manifestiert, was ja dann die Autoren zu der Pointe führt. Die Linksliberalen werden jetzt schon nostalgisch. Die sagen die ganze Zeit, ja, diese Obama-Jahre, das war doch eigentlich schön. Können auch schon gar nicht mehr verstehen, warum Obama vielleicht doch nicht der beste Repräsentant gewesen wäre, um jetzt die George Floyd-Proteste, Black Lives Matters und so zu managen, weil er nun auch Teil des Problems ist. Wird schon gar nicht mehr begriffen. Und das führt eigentlich dann zu der Schlusspointe, dass sie sagen, die Linksliberalen werden am Ende die sein, die am heftigsten versuchen, den Neoliberalismus zu verteidigen.
Ja, es wird eine neue Ideologie geben. Sie verstehen ja das ganze Buch so als heuristisch. Was passiert eigentlich als Nächstes? Und kommen eben am Ende darauf zu sprechen, wir haben es mit diesem neuen Staatskapitalismus zu tun. Der wird natürlich auch aus Corona heraus geboren. Wir fordern ihn ja auch, lieber soll der Staat investieren und dieses Eigentum für alle schaffen, als dass wir weiter dieser FDP-Linie folgen. Bloß keine Staatsschulden, damit alle, die nicht mehr wissen, ob sie noch Deutsche Bank-Aktien oder dann doch direkt bei BlackRock oder wie auch immer, dann einfach sagen, dann kaufe ich mir halt eine Brücke, wenn das so finanziert wird. Und wir werden es mit einer progressiven Technokratie durch eine neue linke Mitte zu tun haben. Auf der einen Seite schauen sie voraus und sagen, ja, die Linke wird sich wohl wieder verschmelzen. Mal gucken, in Deutschland ist ja keine Linkspartei so mehr übrig, mit der sich die SPD gerade verschmelzen kann. Warum sollte sie auch gerade? In Frankreich ist das gerade ein bisschen anders. Da ist der Druck durch die Parlamentswahlen ja entsprechend hoch. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir es mit einer neuen Ideologie zu tun, die zwar wirtschaftlich links argumentiert, kulturell sich aber trotzdem rechts einordnet. Da bin ich mal sehr gespannt. Das sieht man in Deutschland ja immer wieder. Diese hohen Sympathien des Staates in allen möglichen Verwaltungsorganen für dieses eher rechte Denken. Begonnen bei, wo sieht man Polizeigewalt und so weiter? Wo haut die Polizei nicht so richtig drauf und wo dann doch? Wo lässt man doch mal so ein paar Briefe mit Anliegen durchrauschen und behandelt sie und wo blockt man es einfach ab? Da sieht man ja schon, in welche Richtung das so geht. Gerade hier in Deutschland, wo ja noch viel Wohlstand zu verteidigen ist. In deren Sicht, klar, es ist alles nur so ein Versuch in dem Buch, aber bei der Frage, welche Ideologiekämpfe werden nun kommen, versuchen sie, so ein bisschen Antworten zu geben. Und solange liegende Kräfte keine eigene Stimme finden, sagen sie ja, Zitat, stehen wir vor einem Rätsel. Also diese Nuss können sie uns hier auch nicht knacken, dass wir in Deutschland hier schon wieder diese Art der Kritik an der Regierung sehen, natürlich über das Verhalten. Auf der anderen Seite aber eine Bundesregierung, die eben, und das finde ich wirklich bemerkenswert, irgendwie inwieweit. Olaf Scholz eben auch sagt, naja, ich bin hier Kanzler, jetzt bin ich auch noch dreieinhalb Jahre, erst danach findet eine Wiederwahl statt, solange bin ich durchaus bereit, auf eigene Popularität zu verzichten und verkünde nicht selbst, was das Kabinett, das ja mir zuarbeitet, an Erfolgen, sondern nein, Robert Habeck darf gerne selber vor die Kamera gehen und auch nach eigenem Gusto und einfach sagen, welche Erfolge jetzt eingefahren wurden, dass man das EU-Boykott wirklich auch mittragen kann und so, weil man jetzt halt entsprechend gemanagt hat. Also inwieweit Olaf Scholz wirklich gerade Popularitätsverzicht übt, um eben auch ideologischen Druck rauszunehmen, damit wir einfach wohlwollen Texte lesen, die uns erklären, wie Robert Habeck kommuniziert und so. Und dann irgendwie denken, das gelingt ihm aber eigentlich ganz gut.
Oder diese tollen Umfragen, wie beliebt ist welcher Politiker? Und dann sagt man dann immer, ja, da seht ihr es doch. Das ist dann auch so was, was linksliberale Journalisten gerne bei Twitter schreiben. Da seht ihr es doch. Die Deutschen wollen eigentlich Habeck als Kanzler. Und sie begreifen aber nicht, natürlich ist das eine Entscheidung von Scholz, dass Habeck diese Rolle übernimmt. Denken wir doch einfach nur daran, welche Aufgabe hatte Peter Altmaier? Das war so der lustige Grüßonkel, der ein bisschen mit der Industrie gemauschelt hat und so weiter und so fort. Aber ohne dass er da großes verkündet hat. Also es gab in diesen vier Jahren Altmaier doch so gut wie keine Stunde, an die man sich erinnert, wo er da saß und sagt so, ich habe jetzt mal folgendes auf den Weg gebracht. Das war immer ja, wir brauchen eine europäische Cloud oder so. Da hat man mal was gehört und das war es aber dann auch schon. Und wenn es irgendetwas zu verkünden gab, dann hat das Merkel gemacht. Da hat Merkel das für sich genommen und dankte aber auch dem Minister für seine unermüdliche Arbeit. Und Scholz dreht das jetzt um und sagt, geh du raus, ich muss aber jetzt auch gerade nicht in der Infratest-So-und-So-Umfrage besonders beliebt dastehen. Es macht mir nichts.
Genau, also ich finde diesen deutschen Punkt super wichtig, weil die kommen selber drauf zu sprechen. Deutschland hat eine andere Lage als Amerika und England. Diese Art des Wunsches nach Populismus, um so jemanden wie Donald Trump, um so jemanden wie Bernie Sanders, um so jemanden wie Boris Johnson, auch wirklich mal in die Verlegenheit eines Systemfrage-Diskurses zu stellen und das dann auch mit einer Wahl zu entscheiden, haben wir in Deutschland nicht. Ja, wir haben uns mit Außenhandelsüberschüssen und so weiter da einfach so durchgemogelt auch, haben die Franzosen betrogen, das haben wir im Kampf der Nationen gelesen. Alles richtig, aber wir sind jetzt eben in einer Lage, wo ich finde. Und klar, die haben jetzt die deutschen Argumentationen und das, was wir uns einfach nachrichten, die man nicht so im Blick. Aber so wie wir jetzt über Olaf Scholz gesprochen haben, dass wir hier einfach sehen, anhand eines Textes, ah, der macht keine populistische Politik, der leitet uns, der verführt uns nicht zu so einer Antipolitik, bei der wir einfach kritisch daneben stehen und uns wieder selbst geißeln und auf Twitter, aber nur mit Zynismus überschütten, das sagen sie ja auch. Die Abkehr vom Zynismus ist erstmal das Allerwichtigste, um überhaupt zur Pfad zu finden zu den neuen Debatten. Und mit neuer Debatte ist dann eben das Ende des Endes der Geschichte gemeint. Dass es jetzt wieder was zum Streiten gibt, neue Anerkennungs- und Triebfedern und die, also dass einfach wieder sozusagen jeder mit Skin in the Game an der Debatte teilnimmt und nicht einfach nur Jux und Tollerei und Dank Culture auf Twitter ausbreitet. Und ich finde, Olaf Scholz macht uns gerade ein krasses Angebot, uns mit Politik auseinanderzusetzen, bei der wir anders als die Amerikaner und die Briten nicht als erstes sagen, an liebsten wird mir erst mal das ganze System über einen Haufen werfen, sondern er macht bewusst antipopulistische Politik. Klar, keine großen Entscheidungen, er lässt aber eben die Handwerker da werkeln. Habe ich gemacht sein Ding, Berbock macht ihr Ding, sie fährt jetzt wohl nach Kiew. Stellvertretend natürlich für Olaf Scholz dann und so weiter und so fort. Und ich finde in diesem Buch steckt für uns Deutsche so eine Lehre drinnen, wenn wir die politische Debatte weiter so führen, wie wir es jetzt gerade führen, könnten wir es in fünf oder zehn Jahren durchaus mit einer Debatten-Notlage zu tun haben, bei der wir uns auch ein Ende des Endes der Geschichte wünschen.
Ja.
Aber so weit sind zum Glück in Deutschland noch nicht.
Tatsächlich bei vielen Journalisten schon ab. Also dieser unglaubliche Wunsch, involviert zu sein in diesen Krieg und auch mal Eskalation zuzulassen, bis hin dazu, dass dann Journalisten wirklich bei Twitter geschrieben haben, na ja, aber wenigstens würden wir bei einem dritten Weltkrieg auf der richtigen Seite stehen, wo man denkt, wo sind wir jetzt angekommen? Das, glaube ich, ist aber nicht der Wille der Bevölkerung. Es gibt ja jetzt so diese Umfragen, wie viele Menschen in Deutschland wollen, schwere Waffenlieferungen. Und dann merkt man schon, ah, okay, es sind gar nicht so viele, wie das gesagt wird. Es sind dann doch 45 Prozent dagegen. Und da stellt sich schon die Frage, wie ist man dann an die herangetreten? Hat man denen gesagt, die Ukrainer leiden dort furchtbar? Haben wir da nicht auch die Verantwortung, Waffen zu liefern? Und sagt man dann Ja oder Nein? Oder war die Frage, es gibt ja die Gefahr eines Atomkriegs, sollte Deutschland dennoch Waffen liefern? Und dann, glaube ich, würde diese Umfrage schon gänzlich anders aussehen. Und das wird aber in dieser Weise nicht gestellt. Denn meine These ist ja auch, und die Autoren bestätigen es, eigentlich wollen die Deutschen Langeweile. Also die sind noch nicht in diesem Punkt, wo sie eigentlich sagen, es muss jetzt mal wieder was los sein, wir brauchen jetzt mal richtig Rabatz. Klar, es gab da die Querdenken oder so, aber es ist ja auch immer noch eine kleine Gruppe, wenn man so möchte, wenn man für die gesamte Bevölkerung sieht. Die meisten Menschen haben sich impfen lassen, haben sich gefreut, möglichst früh geimpft zu werden und so weiter. Das heißt, wir haben es mit Bürgern zu tun, die eigentlich vielleicht auch durch die Geschichte, die doch noch in einer Weise präsent ist, wie das in anderen Ländern vielleicht nicht so der Fall ist. Denn wir haben diese vielen Gedenktage. Wir haben noch sehr klar vielleicht auch in der eigenen Verwandtschaft vor Augen, was Kriege bedeuten können und auch das Wissen, was wir angerichtet haben als deutsches Volk, dass man eigentlich diese Ruhe noch weiterhin will. Und wenn man sich mal das Kandidatenangebot jetzt ansieht, Merkel war eine Kanzlerin der Langeweile, wenn man so möchte, Helmut Kohl sowieso. Dann aber jetzt auch danach war eigentlich der Wunsch mit Scholz als Kanzler, mit Laschet als Kanzler auch dieser große Wunsch, Habeck als Kanzler zu haben. Und ich meine das nicht abwertend, das sind langweilige Kanzler, sondern mit Langeweile meine ich jetzt wirklich, bitte nicht eine Aufregung, nicht Furore, nicht die große Umwälzung, sondern dass alles ganz gut weiterläuft und an den einen oder anderen Stellen auch mal jetzt härter durchgegriffen wird. Das mit Sicherheit, also nicht einfach nur Verwaltung des Status quo, aber das scheint da zu sein. Es gibt ein interessantes Buch von Basso und Proc, das heißt, musealisiert euch. Und da geht er so ein bisschen auch noch mal Richard Wagner's Spuren entlang und sagt eigentlich so von Wagner aus gibt es diese Linie, die Kunst muss jetzt in Aktivismus umschlagen und wir müssen jetzt was tun. Wir müssen eigentlich aus Bayreuth lernen und wir müssen Deutschland in Bayreuth verwandeln. Und dann sagt Basso und Proc das ist quasi das, was Hitler gemacht hat. Deswegen ist Hitler so gerne nach Bayreuth. Und es gibt dann so ein Satz von Atmut Zerlinski, der sagte erst hat sich Wagner mit den Deutschen verwechselt und später die Deutschen sich mit Wagner. Und dann sagt Basso und Proc aber, was passiert nach dem Krieg? Nach dem Krieg sagen die Deutschen sich nie mehr soll uns ein Pamphlet, ein Gedicht, ein Manifest aus dem Sessel hervorholen. Wir hängen die Führerporträts ab. Stattdessen hängen wir an die Wand die Poster von Roy Black und Rex Gildo, gucken die Abendunterhaltung und wir wollen nicht mehr, ja genau, wir wollen jetzt nicht mehr mitmachen. Das ist jetzt, wir sind jetzt einmal drauf reingefallen und jetzt ist wirklich gut. Und ich glaube, dass dieses Gefühl noch relativ stark vertreten ist, weshalb auch so ein grundsätzliches Misstrauen da ist, sobald gesagt wird, die Deutschen müssen mal in der Welt wieder mehr Verantwortung übernehmen. Und alle denken sofort, wenn sie ein bisschen geschichtsbewusst sind, nicht schon wieder.
Ja und es ist augenöffnend, wie sehr das in Deutschland gerade eine Generationenfrage ist. Da hängt natürlich auch dran, welche Generationen bewendet welche Medien und so. Ja, aber es ist auffällig und da steckt auch einiges drin, was wirklich zu augenöffnenden Aussagen führt.
Ja, die Zukunft sieht also so aus, dass wir da verschiedene Blöcke haben. Wir haben zum einen sagen jetzt die Autoren die großen antipolitischen Rechten, aber die Rechten werden nicht. Auch das ist ja eine kühne These, die sicherlich im linksliberalen Spektrum nicht nur auf Zustimmung stoßen wird, die nicht in den Faschismus führen wird. Also das heißt, wir haben es hier nicht mehr mit einer Bewegung zu tun, die in dem Sinne so ein faschistisches Reinheitsprogramm verordnet, sondern dieser Rechtspopulismus ist viel bunt schäckiger. Der sieht ganz anders aus. Er ist aber nicht mehr vergleichbar mit diesem Faschismus. Das ist sehr gut argumentiert. Worauf wird er sich verlagern? Die Rechtsradikalen werden das Thema Klimawandel neu für sich definieren. Also lange Zeit hatten wir diese Bewegung, gibt es gar nicht, leugnen wir, ist die Sonne. Jetzt wird man sagen, ja, den gibt es. Aber das Problem sind ja nicht wir, die wir, nur wenige Kinder haben, sondern da, wo noch viele Kinder auf der Welt sind, wo die großen Massen sind, das ist das Problem. Man wird in so ein Malthusianisches Denken kommen, also Überbevölkerung, solche Themenkreise werden dann aufgenommen. Also das ist auch eine ganz hässliche Seite eines Rechtspopulismus. Aber es ist etwas anderes als dieser klassische Faschismus. Also das Ökologische und das Rechtspopulistische könnten sich da in einer Weise verbinden, wo auch dann Vorsicht angesagt ist von Seiten der Klimaaktivisten, dass man da nicht plötzlich vor einen falschen Karren gespannt wird. Bei den Linksliberalen ist es so, dass sie nicht in irgendeiner Weise mit einer sozialistischen Linken zu rechnen haben, sondern sie müssen sich an den Neoliberalismus geradezu ketten, heißt es da. Der Linksliberalismus des kommenden Jahrzehnts lässt sich daher am besten als progressive Technokratie verstehen. In dem Maße, in dem sich die technokratische Regierungsform von ihrer neoliberalen Hülle löst, wird die linke Mitte sie noch stärker annehmen, da sie nun nicht mehr mit der neoklassischen Wirtschaftslehre verbunden ist. Das ist nicht verwunderlich, denn diese Linke vertritt vor allem die Interesse der PMC, die sich durch ihr hohes kulturelles Kapital und ihr Bekenntnis zu uneigennütziger Rationalität auszeichnet. Also Listen to the Science und so weiter. Es ist eine Ironie der Geschichte, dass im kommenden Jahrzehnt diejenigen, die sich mit der Linken identifizieren, am meisten für die Verteidigung und Ausweitung der progressiven Aspekte des Neoliberalismus sein werden. Evidenzbasierte Politik, multikulturelle Toleranz, Globalisierung und so weiter. Das konnte man ja schon sehen, dass plötzlich so Freihandel für für Linksliberale etwas war, was man verteidigen musste. Naja, und auf der konservativen Seite, und da können wir ja mal überlegen, ob sich März in diese Richtung entwickeln wird, erleben wir dann eine Politik, die erkennt, ja, trickle down ist wirklich tot. Das kann nicht funktionieren. Biden hat es gesagt. Die Konservativen hier haben es noch nicht erkannt. Aber die werden das in gewisser Weise erkennen, werden also doch wieder daran denken, mehr Wohlstand zu schaffen. Aber man muss sagen, für die eigenen Leute, das heißt, wir werden Protektionismus erleben, wir werden aber auch harte Grenzregime erleben, die diesen Wohlstand schützen sollen für die konservative Wählerschaft. Und das ist natürlich der Versuch, den Rechtspopulisten das Wasser abzugraben. Es ist aber auch ein ganz klares Zeichen, dass man eine sehr egoistische Politik fahren wird, die vielleicht der Gesamtbevölkerung wieder doch mehr Wohlstand zukommen lassen will. Nach den neoliberalen Jahren, die aber in keiner Weise jetzt eine weltoffenere Gesellschaft meint.
Genau. Das wäre nämlich auch mein abschließender Gedanke. Auf die CDU kommen sie ja ausdrücklich zu sprechen. Sie muss nach Merkel jetzt überlegen, wie weit nach rechts sie sich das zutraut. Und relativ früh im Buch kommen sie ja auf das Ende des Endes der Geschichte zu sprechen. Mit diesem, es gibt einen Wunsch nach neuer Politik. Da würde ich den Autoren unterstellen. Ja, das ist halt ihr Wunsch, dass es jetzt diese neue Politik gibt. Wie gesagt, aus Deutschland nicht ganz so zurechtfertig, wie aus anderen, den angelsächsischen Ländern. Aber dieser Wunsch nach neuer Politik, und da würde ich sagen, ist 2016, jetzt sechs Jahre her, so der Zenit, das hat sich ja auch die sechs Jahre vorher angedeutet. Also durch die Obama-Jahre wurde das aufgebaut. Dann gab es 2016 dieses Feuerwerk. Seitdem haben wir diese Nachwirkung und auch wieder die Gefahr, dass es sich 2016 wiederholt. Und hier kommen die mit dieser Beobachtung, dieser aufkommende Wunsch im Westen nach neuer Politik pasierte, ko-evoluierte, müsste man sagen, gleichzeitig mit dieser Formfindung des chinesischen autokratischen Systems. Und jetzt stellt sich die Frage, finden wir eine große kritische Ströme, die sozusagen im Widerstreit zu China die Systemfrage stellt. Also so wie Biden da einfach dasteht, wir brauchen eine neue Familienpolitik, weil das ist der Nukleus der Gesellschaft und da müssen wir dann wirklich gegenhalten. Oder haben wir sowas wie Frank Thelen, jetzt bei Jung und Naiv war das ja, ich hab dich in einem Clip gesehen, wie er meinte, kann ich einfach Habeck mal vier Jahre machen, muss da immer die Demokratie so dazwischen funken. Und wir kennen das auch von Lindner, dass er so zu spät in so einer Plasberg-Sendung auftaucht und das allererste, was er sagt, wir wachsen so, wir wachsen so, China wächst 7,8 Prozent, wir müssen da mithalten. Dann auch wieder diese etwas angegruselte Bewunderung von Friedrich Merz, wie das da in China läuft, der natürlich auch so ein Systemstreit formuliert, aber da wissen wir nicht, wie attraktiv es dann doch für ihn ist, sich auch einfach als Person vorzustellen, die es vielleicht auch machen könnte wie G, wenn man ihm nur die Freiheiten gibt. Also diese Attraktivität ist ja durchaus gegeben. Und da stelle ich mir so die Frage, wenn ich das so lese in diesem Buch, versuchen wir jetzt gegen China Kulturkampf zu machen, Systemstreit oder versuchen wir China nachzuahmen? Es ist irgendwie noch unentschieden, finde ich. Und das ist ein bisschen gefährlich, das so zu beobachten.
Besser kann man es nicht auf den Punkt bringen. Das ist die große Gefahr. Aber ein Buch, das wir empfehlen zur Lektüre.
Richtig. Unbedingt. Selten ist so eine schöne Streitschrift mal wieder gesehen. Das hat man ja selten, dass es auch mal richtig zur Sache geht.
Das Buch Das Ende des Endes der Geschichte haut auf die Pauke. Und das ist so herrlich erfrischend, denn diese Streitschrift zeigt uns auf wunderbare Weise, wo wir politisch gerade stehen, ordnet das Terrain und zeigt uns, wo es hingeht mit dem Linksliberalismus, mit dem Konservatismus und auch dem Rechtspopulismus. Es ist ein Buch, das einen manchmal resignativ zurücklässt, aber das uns zeigt, dass politisch gerade so viel Neues passiert, dass wir wirklich in einer Art Zeitenwende leben. Und diese Zeitenwende wird gut vermessen von den Autoren.
Und gerade wir Deutschen sollten das mit der Streitschrift ganz ernst nehmen. Das Buch liegt auf Deutsch vor und wir dankenswerterweise können es auch noch mal unter dem Aspekt lesen, dass unser Karren noch nicht in die Wand eingeschlagen ist, sondern hier uns noch gezeigt wird, wie wir noch mal die eine oder andere Rechts- oder Linkskurve machen können, in deren Sicht auch ein bisschen Trost spenden.
Wir sprechen über die Zukunft des Luxus von Erwan Rambourg. Er ist ein Mann, der für die großen Portfolios verantwortlich ist. Ein Autor, der schaut, wo kann man investieren und der sich mit dem Luxus seit vielen Jahren beschäftigt, der schon einmal ein Buch darüber geschrieben hat. Jetzt ist ein neues erschienen, Die Zukunft des Luxus, neue Kunden, neue Werte, eine Branche vor Veränderungen. Stefan, was bedeutet eigentlich für dich Luxus?
Ich war ein bisschen überrascht, als ich es dann im Buch las, was für ihn Luxus bedeutet. Für mich war Luxus zu teuer, zu unnotwendig und auch immer so ein bisschen Dekadenz und übertreiben. Für mich hängt Luxus sehr an Produkten und weniger an so kleinen Projekten, wie zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, man leit sich nur irgendwas oder man macht nur einen Ausflug und label den unter Luxus. Also in der Ansicht, ich habe schon noch mal einen neuen Luxus kennengelernt hier.
Luxus ist für mich in erster Linie Komfort. Also dass ich es bequem habe. Das ist für mich das Entscheidende. Luxus ist für mich nicht irgendetwas, was belastend ist. Und das ist vielleicht auch der Unterschied zu vielen Kunden, die da beschrieben werden. Denn viele halten sich ja mit Luxus wirklich etwas auf. Man muss nämlich diese Luxusprodukte auch in gewisser Weise pflegen, muss sich mit ihnen tiefer auseinandersetzen. Und ich bin hier ein Mensch, und ich glaube, das verbindet mich mit dir, der eigentlich friktionslos durch den Alltag gehen möchte. Ich habe keine Lust, mich ewig mit einem Produkt auseinanderzusetzen, sondern wenn sich etwas als gut erwiesen hat, dann kaufe ich das einfach wieder und dann ist Schluss. Ich mag es nicht, mich stundenlang in irgendwas groß einzulesen oder so. Ich vergleiche auch ungern, wenn ich eine neue Tasche brauche, eine Ledertasche, ich weiß es noch, das war im letzten Jahr, das war 20 Minuten Internetrecherche und dann hatte ich sie aber auch, die ich wollte. Da gab es zwei, die zur Wahl standen, dann war die eine ausverkauft, dann habe ich die andere genommen. Die waren dann vielleicht nicht billig, also in gewisser Weise auch ein Luxusprodukt, aber jetzt, wenn man das hier vergleicht, dann niedrige Preisklasse, aber dann ist die Entscheidung getroffen und dann möchte ich mich nicht weiter damit auseinandersetzen, während hier ja doch auch viele Kunden geschildert werden, die aus einer Langeweile heraus oder aus einem Mangel an Lebenssinn heraus sich intensiv mit Produkten beschäftigen wollen, die da auch noch eine Philosophie mitgeliefert haben wollen, die eine Geschichte des Unternehmens erklärt haben wollen. All das eigentlich, was mir überflüssiger Tand erscheint, das ist aber für die Luxusprodukte oft enorm wichtig.
Zunehmend. Es waren lange so diese Produkte, also einfach das Signal, hier mein Auto, mein Dings und so. Jetzt wird es zunehmend wichtiger. Ich finde interessant, dass das Buch direkt losgeht, über Frauen zu schreiben. Frauen als die neuen Konsumenten. Denn die Frauen verwalteten ja schon immer das Familiengeld, nur eben nicht für sich. Jetzt kamen so die Selbstverwirklichung dazu, korreliert natürlich mit Rentnerrepublikanischen. Ich habe es ja vorhin schon gesagt, es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie viel Rentnerrepublik hier schon drin steckt. Frauen werden angehalten, mehr zu arbeiten, um das Arbeitnehmerpotenzial besser auszubeuten. Auch Mütter zurück in den Job und so. Was eben bedeutet, dass die Frauen mehr eigenes Geld haben, worauf die Luxus-Marken jetzt immer mehr Bezug nehmen. Und dann eben auch die Werbekampagnen direkt um die Frauen herum stricken. Diese Definition von Luxus hat mich insgesamt sehr überrascht. Es geht mehr um Psychologie und weniger um das verfügbare Geld. Das ist so ein bisschen die gleiche These, also im gleichen Spektrum auf der anderen Seite, wie ihr das Influencer über das Prekariat geschrieben hat. Ja, die Influencer verdienen wahnsinnig viel Geld, aber sie wissen immer nicht genau, auch nächsten Monat noch. Sondern es hängt alles am seitenden Faden und hier ja auch. Also die Entscheidung für einen Luxus kann durchaus mal so ein Monatsgehalt dann aufzehren. Ein kleiner Städtetrip oder so, wie auch immer, gestaltet. Was natürlich auch für die Werbeidee dann bedeutet, dass man da reingehen kann. Also dass man ganz breit werben kann. Er schlüsselt ja dann ausführlich auf, wie kompliziert es ist für die Marken, so eine Preisfindung für sich selber zu machen. Also geht man so ins breite Spektrum, da kommt man aber nie wieder zurück in dieses Exklusivitätsding. Wenn man da aber ist, verliert man vielleicht das Potenzial, wirklich einen sehr viel höheren Absatz zu haben. Also es ist super kompliziert. Mir war ein bisschen unklar, wie weit es mittlerweile wirklich getrieben wird. Also dass zum Beispiel Nike, oder Nike wie wir in Deutschland sagen, eine Milliarde Dollar ausgibt für einen Exklusivvertrag, für einen Sportler, nämlich Lebron Jones, James. Ich habe das nochmal nachgoogeln wollen. Es war nicht so leicht zu finden. Also die Verträge selbst sind intransparent, zumindest für die Öffentlichkeit. Aber es scheint tatsächlich ein Milliardenvertrag zu sein. Da steckt ja so die Kalkulation dahinter, dass sich das für die Marke tatsächlich rechnet, über die Produktpalette so viel abzusetzen, weil man einer Person als Werbekörper eine Milliarde Dollar gegeben hat. Also das ist einfach absurd, auf welchem Niveau das sich mittlerweile abspielt.
Ja, um mal grad einzuhacken, noch mal zu dem Thema Frauen. Ich hörte kürzlich einen Podcast mit dem Chef von Mytherisa. Das ist auch eine Plattform, auf der man Luxusmode shoppen kann. Und der sagte, früher war das bei der Luxusmode so. Es waren die Frauen reicher Männer, die Luxusmode kauften. Inzwischen sind unsere Kunden, unsere Kundinnen reiche Frauen. Denn das sind Frauen, die arbeiten und die besonders Online-Handel frequentieren. Dann er sagte, die haben überhaupt keine Zeit, auf der Maximilianstraße in München fünf Stunden am Nachmittag rumzurennen. Die sind ja am Arbeiten. Die kommen nach Hause, dann ist 19 Uhr, dann bringt man vielleicht noch die Kinder ins Bett und dann geht man zum Online-Shopping über. Und da verändert sich gerade unglaublich viel. Also dieser Sektor, glaube ich, erlebt so eine Disruption, die aber nicht in irgendeiner Weise schädlich ist für den gesamten Luxussektor, sondern vielleicht für den Einzelhandel etwas. Aber diese Disruption sorgt dafür, dass da ein unglaublicher Markt entsteht, weil Frauen natürlich dann noch mehr über ihr Geld verfügen können. Und auch dadurch, dass diese finanzielle Möglichkeit da ist, ist also die Frau nicht allein darauf reduziert, ähm, quasi ästhetisches Beiwerk zu sein, wie das jetzt in den 50er Jahren, man kann es in Doris Day filmen oder so nachvollziehen, noch der Fall ist. Was aber auch bedeutet, dass die Männer wiederum, um gleichziehen zu können mit den Frauen, nicht einfach sagen können, ja, ich habe ja das Geld, dann sagen die ja, habe ich ja selbst. Also müssen die auch in gewisser Weise ihre Ästhetik hervorbringen, müssen diese optimieren und müssen sich auch mit entsprechenden Luxusgegenständen auseinandersetzen und damit ausstatten.
Frauen sind, Zitat, auch Autoritäten beim Geschmack. Das ist das Neue. Sie haben jetzt nicht nur das Familien-Einkommen, sondern eigenes Geld und generieren darüber eigenen Geschmack. Da steckt viel Rentenrepublik drin, auch in der Beobachtung, die kommenden Kunden sind Asiens Mittelschicht. 88 Prozent aller, die in die Mittelklasse aufsteigen, wohnen in Asien. Es ist China, das die Leute aus der Armut geholt hat. Und es wird ein Wachstum von zwei Milliarden Menschen von 2015 bis 2030 erwartet, die so ungefähr auf 35.000 Dollar Jahresgehalt kommen. Also in deren Sicht, das ist für das Klima eine Herausforderung, aber eben auch hier für die Luxus-Marken. Ich habe diese Teile nicht konkret und tief gelesen, aber dass einige Marken doch wahnsinnig schlecht gemanagt werden und er selbst dann nochmal Management-Tipps gibt, finde ich interessant. Denn da scheint noch einiges Potenzial, also so BWL-Potenzial, einfach trostlos auf dem Boden zu liegen. Da kann man sehr gespannt sein, was als nächstes kommt. Denn die Konkurrenz ist ja da, das fand ich dann wieder interessant. Ähm, Apple. Und dieser ganze Versuch Luxus, also seine Definition von Luxus, klar, Produkte und so weiter, aber auch allein Gesundheit. Gesunde Ernährung ist Luxus, sagt er. Wir ernähren uns so schlecht, dass gesunde Ernährung schon Luxus ist, also schon ins Luxussegment fällt.
Bis hin zum Schlafen.
Schlafen, essen, bewegen, genau.
In Italien eine neue Klinik, ich habe den Namen gerade vergessen, die wie ein Luxushotel funktioniert, eine Privatklinik. Dort kann man alle möglichen Behandlungen machen lassen. Keine Schönheitsbehandlung, die natürlich auch, aber auch wirkliche nötige Operationen oder gesamte Check-ups, dass man da zwei, drei Wochen alles mal testen lassen kann, was man immer schon machen wollte und aber keine Lust hat zum Arzt zu gehen. Das ist dann eingebettet in einen solch luxuriösen Rahmen mit einem 3-Sterne-Restaurant und all dem, was man sonst überall einzeln suchen müsste. Das ist da in so einem großen Ressort. Es ist unbezahlbar quasi für Leute, die in irgendeiner Weise normal verdienen. Also es ist, ich hatte dann Zahlen gelesen, sieben Tage 24.000 Euro. Von solchen Summen sprechen wir da plus dann noch entsprechende Zusatzkosten bei irgendwelchen Behandlungen. Und das ist aber etwas, was mir sofort eingeleuchtet hat, was mir aber auch wieder eine interessante Frage öffnete. Du hattest es, glaube ich, vor zwei Folgen, in der vorvorherigen Folge gesagt, dass du jetzt zum ersten Mal die neuesten Apple-Produkte hast. Also du hast das neue iPhone und du hast diese Apple-Bot. Und damit bist du jetzt genauso ausgestattet wie der Milliardär. Also der kann jetzt auch bei Apple nicht höher steigen. Aber ich nehme jetzt die Uhr für 10.000 Euro. Die gibt es halt gar nicht.
Er lässt sich das Gehäuse noch veredeln. Das geht. Aber technisch gesehen sind wir auf Augenhöhe. Und das schreibt er hier auch. Apple hat natürlich am Anfang sehr viele Produkte verkauft. Dann kam irgendwie die Software und jetzt sind es die Services. Und die sind ein immer größerer Anteil. Und die stehen schon auf der Bühne und sagen dann zumindest den Investoren gegenüber Fitness und Health. Das sind unsere beiden Wachstumsdinger. Da wollen wir so richtig rein. Machen sie ja jetzt auch. Es gibt ein neues Buch über Apple nach Steve Jobs. Das heißt irgendwie so After Steve oder so. Da war der Autor bei Kara Swisher und Scott Galloway im Podcast. Und er hat es auch nochmal betont, dass Apple ja eigentlich noch so eine neue, hm, jetzt hat man halt das iPhone noch von Steve Jobs machen lassen. Und die Uhr so als Geisel des iPhones hat dann Tim Cook noch auf den Weg gebracht. Aber was ist eigentlich das nächste große Ding? Und klar, diese alten Kommentatoren, die sagen, ich hab seit dem ersten Apple-Computer wenig dabei und so weiter, die warten natürlich auf Produkte. Aber Apple ist schon bei drei Billionen Marktkapitalisierung und zwar über diese Services und über die Versprechen, die da drin sind. Und die Apple Watch einfach mit dem Service zu verkaufen, damit kannst du deine Großmutter so überwachen, dass du quasi erkennst und dann auch einen Hilferuf bekommst, wenn sie die Treppe runterfällt und so weiter. Das ist ja dann noch gar nicht eingepreist im Denken, aber bei Apple natürlich schon voll und ganz in so einer Bilanz.
Und man kann sie abonnieren, man kann die Geräte jetzt abonnieren bei Apple. Das ist ja auch etwas Neues, was erstaunlich ist. Also Hardware kann man mieten jetzt bei Apple.
Das ist ja was, was ich meine, ist neu. Also es gibt auf jeden Fall, genauer schreibt er ja, diese Luxus-Kreislaufwirtschaft, dass man sich für Gelegenheiten Sachen einfach nimmt. Da sind wir ja eh weg vom Eigentum. Also man kann ja heute mit der S-Klasse einfach mal rumfahren. Man mietet sich halt einfach für ein Wochenende. Und dann kostet es zwar ein bisschen was, aber eben nicht das ganze Auto. Also in der Hinsicht, ja, das ist ein ganz interessanter Ausblick am Ende auch. Also ich finde es sehr optimistisch, wie er das Fazit zieht, dass die Leute wissen wollen, wo ihr Kram herkommt und so. Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Nein, nein, also er geht dann ganz auf diese Nachhaltigkeitssachen ein und dass das so wichtig ist. Und klar, wenn man sich so ein bisschen diese Luxus-Leute die also CEOs von diesen Unternehmen sind, jetzt gerade anhört, dann hat man den Eindruck, die wollen nichts mehr anderes als das 1,5 Grad Ziel erreichen. Natürlich ist das purer Nonsens, sondern Luxusprodukte funktionieren, du hast es eben gesagt, über Psychologie. Und die funktionieren über Erzählungen. Und die Erzählung ist noch immer, wie vor 100 Jahren damals in der italienischen Provinz, werden diese Lederwaren gefertigt. Und dann soll diese Aura der Nostalgie sich übertragen auf das, was man dann vorfindet, im hochmodernen Einkaufszentrum. Und selbstverständlich kann man diese Narrative auch weiter anreichern, zum Beispiel jetzt durch sowas wie Nachhaltigkeit. Und sicherlich haben die, da die Gewinnmargen eh so verrückt hoch sind, da alle Möglichkeiten, das besser ökologisch zu gestalten, aber zu glauben, dass Luxus-Mode oder Luxus-Waren nachhaltig sind, ist, glaube ich, sehr albern. Denn natürlich funktioniert das alles nur dadurch, dass viel konsumiert wird und zwar mehr als man braucht. Also Luxus ist ja gerade nie das, was man braucht. Und sie bringen dann das Beispiel von einem Unternehmen, bringt dann eher von Patagonia, die so eine Werbekampagne gemacht haben. Kaufen Sie diese Jacke nicht. Und das ist eigentlich die typische Ideologie unserer Zeit. Man macht eine Werbung, weist auf eine Jacke hin und sagt, kaufen Sie die nicht, dann denken Sie an den Klimawandel. Und dann wird da versprochen, ein Prozent des Erlöses geht sonst wohin. Wir kennen das alles. Und der Effekt war ja, das schreibt er dann selbst, dass sich der Umsatz des Unternehmens, das diese Werbung geschaltet hat, gesteigert hat. Das heißt, man hat noch mal da eine Nische entdeckt. Also inwieweit können wir aus Konsumkritik auch noch mal ein gutes Produkt machen? Und das hat man da einfach erreicht. Und wenn man sich mal so ansieht, wie Luxus auch sonst beworben wird, neben dieser Nachhaltigkeitssparte, dann wird Luxus nach wie vor als das hedonistische, das gönne ich mir, das bin ich mir wert verkauft. Und das war auch so eine Erfahrung von Ohle und mir, während wir zu den Influencern recherchiert haben. Ja, es gibt natürlich die, die dieses Nachhaltigkeitsthema jetzt für sich erkannt haben. Aber es gibt auch nach wie vor die, die sagen, ja, ich habe jetzt fünf Ferrari's mir gekauft, guck mal, und die lasse ich jetzt mal richtig fliegen. Und da ist nichts mit Nachhaltigkeit vorhanden. Kanntest du denn diese Marken alle, die da so genannt wurden? War das, war das für dich?
Nee, also diese richtigen Hintergrutmarken so nicht, sondern nur die allgemein bekannten.
Also fast alles gehört ja LVMH.
Ja, das sagt mir gar nichts.
Oder Kehring. Also das ist, naja, das sind ja die beiden Franzosen. Einmal Arnaud und Pinot. Arnaud ist ja befreundet mit Bernhard Arnaud, mit den Macron. Deswegen trägt Brigitte Louis Vuitton. Das ist da die Connection. Kehring hat Gucci gekauft. Und das sind so Konsortien, die ganz viele Luxusmarken haben. Zum Beispiel hat LVMH auch vor einer Weile Tiffany gekauft. Und dann gibt es noch so ein paar Unternehmen, die eigenständig sind und wo man sich dann fragt, wann werden die dann irgendwann gekauft? Zum Beispiel gibt es Rolex, das ist in eine Stiftung verwandelt. Dann gibt es Hermes, Chanel, die gehören den Brüdern Wertheimer.
Genau, die Marken sind alle bekannt, aber dass es da diese Konsortien im Hintergrund gibt, das wusste ich nicht.
Und die sind aber noch unabhängig. Hermes, Rolex und Chanel sind noch unabhängig. Das ist aber wahrscheinlich auch nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis entweder Kehring oder LVMH zugreifen wird.
Ja, also er macht ja diese ganzen Interviews mit diesen Chefs oder wie auch immer der Unternehmen. Ich habe mich am Ende auch gefragt, warum man das nicht noch einfach mal durchkalkuliert. Wir wissen ja aus dem Lieferkettengesetz, dass selbst eine nicht-Luxushose zu 80% aus Marketing-Budget besteht und nur 7 Euro oder so dann noch mal an die Nähereien fällen. Wenn wir jetzt so Luxus-Dinger haben, wie dieses T-Shirt von Mark Zuckerberg, ist einfach nur grau, es ist Stoff, aber es kostet halt 350 Dollar, dann können wir ja ermessen, dass das halt, was weiß ich, 95, 98, 99% Marketing ist. Wenn man da jetzt noch Nachhaltigkeit mit einwebt, dann ist das so 10% des Dings irgendwie, aber eben nicht des Ganzen. Also dass das nur eine Sparte, ein kognitiver Anker unter so vielen ist, das kam mir da ein bisschen kurz. Also da war am Ende einfach sehr, naja.
Was ich erstaunlich fand, war diese Idee, dass Luxus ein Beweis ist für die Anerkennung, dass man in der Gesellschaft seinen Platz gefunden hat und dass das gerade für, ich sage jetzt der Einfachheit halber nicht weiße, sehr wichtig ist. Also das zeigt er ja mit seinem globalen Blick ganz gut, dass das nicht so ein westliches Dekadenzphänomen ist, sondern es ist ein globales Phänomen. Und gerade die, die es schaffen, in irgendeiner Weise aufzusteigen, wollen das mit Luxus-Marken dokumentieren. Er verweist zum Beispiel da auf die Hip-Hop-Videos, wo wir das auch deutlich sehen können. Und das ist, glaube ich, nochmal ein sehr guter Punkt, wenn wir auch nochmal an unser Buch, über das wir eben gesprochen haben, denken, dass da gesagt wird, na ja, eigentlich ist so diese linksliberale Logik eng verbunden mit dem Neoliberalismus, also mit dem Versprechen der Anerkennung der Toleranz, der Offenheit, der Globalisierung, der Lieferketten, die überall so sind. Und das zeigt sich da nochmal besonders, wenn man dann sagt, na ja, aber das ist doch eigentlich dann inklusiv insofern, als man es sich kaufen kann, wenn man es sich leisten kann, um zu zeigen, ich gehöre jetzt auch dazu, ich gehöre nicht mehr zu denen, die ausgestoßen sind, denn auch ich trage diese immens teure Tasche von MS Oder glatte Haare.
Also in der Ansicht sehr gute Durchdringung dieses Buches mit demografischen Sachen einfach, die echt eine große Rolle spielen.
Einen Aspekt natürlich noch, der mich umtreibt und der mich sehr traurig gemacht hat, der Anzug. Ich lese das gerade vor. Er fragt sich, ist das jetzt einfach nur ein Trend, dass wir so wenig Anzüge noch sehen? Der sagt, ich halte das eher für einen Generationenwechsel. Ich begegne Investoren am Anfang ihrer Karriere, die um die 30 Jahre alt sind und auf der Arbeit Trainingsanzug und Sneakers tragen. Natürlich handelt es sich bei den Sneakers nicht um irgendwelche, sondern um die neueste Limited Edition von Nike oder um die hochschäftigen Dior B23 für mehr als 1000 Dollar. Aber es sind Sportschuhe. Sportartikel gelten als bequem und cool. Und sobald männliche Verbraucher einmal aufgehört haben, Krawatten zu tragen und irgendwann auch keine Anzüge mehr anziehen, dann kehren sie meiner Ansicht nach wahrscheinlich nicht mehr zurück. Die jüngere Generation will bei der Arbeit flexibler sein, denn die Start-up-Kultur ist zwar ehrgeizig, aber auch locker. Und die Verbraucher wollen sich selbst nicht allzu ernst nehmen. Sehr traurig, diese Entwicklung. Vielleicht ist dann der Anzug wieder etwas, was wir woanders finden. Vielleicht muss die Arbeiterklasse den Anzug jetzt für sich entdecken, habe ich schon überlegt.
Oder wir freuen uns darüber, dass bei punktuellen Anlässen dann doch der Anzug festlich getragen wird.
Ja, aber ich finde, ich bin ja auch für ein schönes Stadtbild oder wenn man im Zug sitzt. Also ich will die Revolution der Arbeiterklasse im Anzug gerne anführen. Da muss man nochmal drüber nachdenken, ob das möglich ist. Na ja, sonst bekommt man so ein paar Details, über die man gar nicht nachdenkt. Zum Beispiel, wie wichtig Duty-Free-Shopping geworden ist. Also Leute fliegen irgendwo hin an einen Flughafen, sind dort in riesigen Shopping-Malls unterwegs und fliegen dann sofort wieder nach Hause. Das heißt, man fliegt nur irgendwo hin, um einzukaufen und hat dort mal an einem Ort alle großen Marken von MS bis Louis Vuitton, kauft dort dann Duty-Free und kann dann wieder nach Hause oder man errichtet solche Duty-Free-Zonen innerhalb eines Landes. Also in China ist das ja passiert. Das beschreibt dann da dann Boutique-Hotels, also Hotels, die gleichzeitig Shopping-Center sind. All das wird hier so ein bisschen aufgebröselt. Oder dann auch dieser Trend des hässlichen Schuhs von Balenciaga, dass man eigentlich Schuhe produziert. Und das habe ich auch immer häufiger festgestellt, so in der Sneaker-Mode. Schuhe, die einfach richtig hässlich sind, die aber immens teuer sind. Und dass das dann auch wieder etwas ist, was funktionieren kann. Ja, es ist eine Welt, die in einem Wandel begriffen ist. Das führt auch dazu, dass dann einzelne Personen, wie du es jetzt schon bei den Sneaker beschrieben hast, so wichtig werden, dass da eigene Unternehmen rum entstehen. Da geht es um die Kooperation von Rihanna mit LVMH, also mit dem Konzern von Anno, wer sich jetzt da ein bisschen einlesen will. Ich würde aber sagen, es wäre eigentlich gut, man hätte jetzt den Autor des Buches mal in so einem 90-minütigen Podcast zu Gast, wo man diese Themen ein bisschen durchspricht, aber man muss das nicht unbedingt lesen. Kommen wir nun zu der Studie Jugend im ländlichen Raum Baden-Württembergs. Man muss diese Studie jetzt nicht komplett behandeln, 124 Seiten lang, aber vielleicht doch so ein paar Ergebnisse sind augenöffnend. Im ländlichen Raum heißt es, da engagieren sich mehr Jugendliche als in der Stadt. 39 Prozent der Jugendlichen auf dem Land engagieren sich, 30 Prozent in der Stadt. Mädchen engagieren sich eher als Jungs. Jugendliche aus dem ländlichen Raum identifizieren sich mehrheitlich mit dem Land, und zwar zu 87 Prozent identifizieren die sich damit. Und da kann man sich ja auch schon die Frage stellen, werden die das Land verlassen, in die Stadt gehen? Eher nicht. 91 Prozent der Jugendlichen in Baden-Württemberg, auf dem Land und in der Stadt, fühlen sich an ihrem jetzigen Wohnort wohl. Und das war für mich das Entscheidende bei dieser Studie. Wenn ich mal an die Diskurse der vergangenen Jahre denke, dann wissen wir das ja, es ist schon zu einer Art Parodie geworden. Die Schwaben verlassen das Schwabenland und wollen alle nach Berlin. Und dann liest man immer mal wieder, wenn Leute dann zurückkommen ins Schwabenland, dann schreiben sie in Kolumnen oder sonst wo. Ich weiß jetzt wieder, warum ich lieber in Berlin in einer WG mit fünf Leuten wohne, als hier in einem Reihenhaus im Schwabenland. Aber möglicherweise ist das auch diese mediale Verzerrung, was wir da erleben. Denn eine solche Umfrage ist ja, auch wenn die nur repräsentativ ist und nicht alle gefragt worden, ist ja doch etwas, wenn da 91 Prozent sagen, nö, eigentlich finde ich das hier gar nicht mal so schlecht. Und das, glaube ich, könnte man jetzt von Baden-Württemberg auch übertragen auf andere ähnliche Länder. Aber Baden-Württemberg ist ja, das muss man doch auch festhalten, ein ziemlich reiches Land, das auch Möglichkeiten vom Land aus bietet an Karrieren, wie das vielleicht in anderen Bundesländern nicht der Fall ist, weil man hier natürlich mit der Autoindustrie zum Beispiel und ihren Zulieferern einige Möglichkeiten hat, die vielleicht dann woanders nicht so sind. Jugendliche auf dem Land möchten lieber eine Ausbildung machen als Gleichaltrige in den Städten. Also auf dem Land sind es 25 Prozent, in den Städten 18 Prozent. Überhaupt ist das Handwerksinteresse auf dem Land größer. Das wundert uns jetzt wiederum nicht. Jugendliche auf dem Land mit einer Migrationsgeschichte, hier wird es wieder interessant, möchten später lieber in einer Stadt oder Großstadt leben. Also 58 Prozent der Menschen mit einem Migrationshintergrund sagen, wir wollen in eine Stadt oder in eine Großstadt. Nur 32 Prozent ohne Migrationshintergrund sagen, wir wollen in die Stadt oder in die Großstadt. Was natürlich klar ist, also auf dem Land, ist, dass sich Anders empfinden und auch dass anders wahrgenommen werden, viel größer als in der Anonymität der Stadt. Das heißt, da gibt es also einen großen Wunsch, aus dieser dörflichen oder ländlichen Enge zu entkommen. Immer wieder wird auch so deutlich gemacht, dass für Jugendliche auch nochmal eine andere Definition von Stadt und Land herrscht. Da müssen wir jetzt nicht näher drauf eingehen. Also was sie als Stadt und was sie als Land empfinden, was dann vielleicht nicht gerade unseren üblichen Definitionen entspricht. Also die Vorstadt ist dann schon das Land und so weiter. Was interessiert, also was ist besonders wichtig? Was macht eine Stadt oder was macht das Land lebenswert? Natur und Umgebung. Das ist das, was am häufigsten genannt wird, mit Abstand am häufigsten genannt wird. Also da kann man ja auch nochmal drüber nachdenken als Politiker, wenn man junge Leute erreichen will, eine gute Umgebung, Schrägstrich Natur schaffen, grüne Innenstadt oder was auch immer, da dann möglich ist. Das ist jedenfalls etwas, was umtreibt. Danach kommt Gemeinschaft und dann kommt Ruhe, wenig Verkehr. Das sind dann die Punkte, die wichtig sind. Und es kommt erst an fünfter Stelle, nach Treffpunkte für Jugendliche, kommt der Wunsch nach Einkaufsmöglichkeiten. Was sich sicherlich auch erklärt, da junge Leute im Netz shoppen, sagen nicht, ich kriege hier ja leider nichts, sondern die kriegen ja ihre Sneaker sowieso maximal noch in Stuttgart, wenn überhaupt. Aber die Limited Edition, die die haben wollen, die gibt es ja doch nur online zu kaufen. Deswegen sind Einkaufsmöglichkeiten gar nicht mehr so wichtig. Ich glaube, da hat sich einiges verändert in den letzten Jahren. Sowohl in der Stadt, als auch auf dem Land, steht die Kategorie Natur und Umgebung an erster Stellung. Die Nennungen beinhaltet neben Natur auch die Umgebung nach Attribute wie gute Lage, die Landschaft, Parks. Das ist also das, was gewünscht wird. Es wird beklagt, dass es zu wenig Treffpunkte für Jugendliche gibt. Und damit sind jetzt nicht nur die klassischen Jugendtreffs gemeint. Beklagt wird auch die schlechte Verkehrsanbindung. Ist auf dem Land natürlich noch ein bisschen schlechter als in der Stadt. Aber auch da sind viele, die mehr als 30 Minuten zur Schule brauchen. Das ist ja nicht wenig, wenn man das mal hochrechnet. Junge Menschen im ländlichen Raum wünschen sich mehr Sportvereine. Und zwar also ganz mit größtem Abstand. Die haben dann mal so aufgezählt, was wünscht ihr euch, alle möglichen Vereine und so was aufgeschrieben. Und der Sportverein steht da an der Spitze. Dann weit abgeschlagen. Aber an zweiter Stelle der Musikverein. Und dann kommt tatsächlich Kirchengemeinden, Glaubensgemeinschaften, dass da mehr getan wird. Und alles andere ist quasi zu vernachlässigen. Die Hälfte der Jugendlichen in Stadt und Land weiß nicht, ob sie sich mit Ideen und Vorschlägen an Zuständige in ihrem Wohnort wenden kann. Also es ist überhaupt nicht gewusst, an wen müsste man sich eigentlich wenden, wenn man sagt, wir hätten mal gerne hier den Jugendtreff. Oder geht es nicht auch so, dass der Bus mal noch diesen einen Schlenker fährt, damit ich auch wirklich gut nach Hause komme. Man weiß überhaupt nicht, an wen man sich wenden soll. Das Auto ist für die, die auf dem Land wohnen, wichtig. Aber ich fand die Zahl dann nicht so hoch. Insgesamt 22 Prozent der Befragten auf dem Land sind für den Schulweg auf das Auto angewiesen. Na gut, es ist ja doch fast ein Viertel. Ja, 22 Prozent. Und in der Stadt wird der Schulweg nur von 10 Prozent mit dem Auto zurückgelegt. Also das ist ja eigentlich dann nicht besonders hoch. 18 Prozent wünscht sich auch schneller, von A nach B zu kommen. Am liebsten heißt es, treffen sich Jugendliche in der Stadt und auf dem Land abends mit Freundinnen und Freunden zu Hause. Da frage ich mich, ob das jetzt schon der Corona-Effekt ist, der sich hier einstellt. Aber die Studie ist ja über einen gewissen Zeitraum. Aber das scheint sehr wichtig, dass man also gar nicht so draußen irgendwie rausgeht, sondern man hat offenbar die Möglichkeiten, sich auch zu Hause zu treffen. Was auch dafür spricht, dass dann die Kinderzimmer entsprechend oder Jugendzimmer entsprechend groß sind, dass man das überhaupt machen kann. Dass nicht gerade dieses sich draußen irgendwo im Lokal, wo auch immer treffen, auf der Parkbank die einzige Möglichkeit ist. Und 40 Prozent, so kann man es zusammenfassen, der Jugendlichen in Stadt und Land möchten später in einem Dorf leben. Also Stefan, deine Idee, dass wir bald diese verwaisten Landstriche haben, die wir der Natur zurückgeben, während dann in den Städten die Hightech-Metropolen entstehen, ich bin mir da unsicher, also die Baden-Württemberger sagen eher nicht.
Genau, wenn man vom Willen ausgeht, ist das immer ein bisschen anders, als wenn man sich dann die biografische Realität, wie sie sich eben ergibt, wenn es heißt, so, jetzt bewerb dich mal, er wurden eigentlich. Und dann muss es auch Gelegenheiten geben. Du hast uns jetzt hiermit eine Studie vom Lande vorgestellt. Und klar, aus vielerlei Sicht könnte man sagen, Baden-Württemberg ist doch ein großes urbanes Zentrum. Nur weil man da mal in 20 Minuten fährt und dann erst in Stuttgart ist, also das ist noch nicht Land. Richtig Land finden wir in Japan. Wir wissen, man lebt an der Küste. Die großen Bergzipfel sind alle menschenleer. Die Wege zu den Bergzipfeln werden auch immer menschenleer. Wir haben es mit einem grandiosen Text zu tun von Greg Mod, M-U-D Mod, wie auch immer. Ein langer Walk, eine lange Wanderung in die verschwindenden Ecken von Japan. A long walk in a fading corner… Singular… A fading… Ich sage gleich welche… Of Japan. Dieser Text ist nicht nur toll geschrieben, sondern hat auch wahnsinnig krasse Bilder, die dann im Text entsprechend beschrieben werden. Also wer sich dafür interessiert, der lese bitte selbst. Ich übersetze hier nur grob und fasse mal zusammen, dass auch innerlich und unter rentenapopulkanischen Gesichtspunkten gar nicht so schlecht ist, das mal zu erfahren, was Deutschland dann auch droht. Also wir reden hier also über die Sächsische Schweiz oder so. Für das ganze, für das ganze ländliche Japan gilt es, Zitat, altert ins Nichts. Aging into nothingness. Hört man die Glocken?
Ja, die Glocken hört man.
Das ist die Rentenapopulik. Soll ich die Glocken läuten lassen oder muss ich das alle… Ja, ich lass sie mal läuten. Das passt vielleicht auch zu dem Text. Der Text beginnt auf dem Gipfel des Hinode Katake. Auf der einen Seite unendliche Bergzipfel, viel Ruhe. Man hört nichts, wenn man da oben steht. Auf der anderen Seite sieht man schon die nächsten urbanen Zentren. Da geht es also zur Sache. Das Ganze findet statt auf Ki Penins… also Ki, K-I-I, so heißt schon die ganze Halbinsel. Es ist die größte Halbinsel, die vom Mainland Honshu abgeht. Und jetzt ist man da, wenn er da zu Fuß wandert. Das klappt. Ansonsten gibt es da die Nanki Zugverbindung oder die National Route 42. Also man kann mit dem Zug schnell durchfahren oder mit dem Auto. Er kommt dann gleich auf die romantischen Geschichten zu sprechen, wie damals vor 200 Jahren verliebte junge Japaner nehmen es auf sich, vom einen urbanen Zentrum ins nächste zu reisen. Das führte natürlich genau durch diese Wege. Heute sieht man da niemanden mehr, denn es sind diese ausgebackerten Schluchten und Tunnel und dann düst man da einfach durch. Und derjenige, der damals noch romantisch schrieb, für dich werde ich die Bergkuppen plätten, um schnell bei dir zu sein und so weiter. Nein, das ist alles schon geschehen. Technischer Fortschritt hat es gebracht. Er selbst war vor zwölf Jahren das erste Mal da und seitdem ist er beeindruckt von der, und so steht es im Text, Fertilität. Nur meint er die Bäume, diese Bäume, diese Natur. Er zog mit 19 Jahren nach Japan, lebt jetzt seit 22 Jahren dort. Und hat im Grunde alles mitgemacht. Mal oben auf dem Koyasan-Tempel, alle möglichen Rituale. Man floated, also man wandert da nicht, sondern man geht da hin und zu wandern, aber am Ende floated man zwischen den Welten. Die letzte 30-Tage-Wanderung, von der er berichtet, da begegnete ihm schon eine Omi, die ihm sagte, Achtung, Achtung, Bären. Ich habe einen Bären gesehen. Also die Natur kommt wirklich zurück in Japan. Man hat jetzt übrigens auch in Bayern mal einen Braunbären gesehen. Sein Lieblingsort, Furusato, fühlt sich zeitlos an. Es ist wie ein Garteneden. Er trifft dort einen Bauer. Die zeigen sich nochmal gegenseitig, wie man diese alten Robenrituell richtig trägt und so weiter. Und dann schreibt er so, ja, hier kann man wirklich wahnsinnig viel falsch machen. Also man fällt als Tourist sofort auf. Man besucht beispielsweise diesen Shinto-Schreien und keiner der Touristen kriegt es in der richtigen Reihenfolge hin, das Geld einzuwerfen, zweimal zu klatschen, sich zu verbeugen. Nein, man muss sich zweimal verbeugen, zweimal klatschen und dann noch einmal verbeugen, nachdem man seine Spende dagelassen hat. Aber es ist eine Kulturlandschaft, die ins Nichts hinein altert. Kaum jemand, der einem dort begegnet, ist unter 50 Jahre alt. Die alten Industrien, die es nach Gab, Teeplantagen zum Beispiel, sind komplett umgewandelt in Solarfarmen. Jedes Mal, wenn der Autor dort ist, sieht er weniger. Zuletzt sein Lieblingscafé La Mer hat geschlossen. Der Inhaber hinterließ noch ein Schild an der Tür. I have aged out of the business. Ich bin aus diesem Business heraus gealtert. Er sagt dann, der Wandel gehört zum Leben, aber. Und das ist ein so warmherziger Appell am Ende des Textes. Er schreibt dann, ich wünsche mir von allen, die diesen Text lesen, dass sie sich jetzt gleich hierher teleportieren. Und dann meint er nochmal, wirklich jetzt gleich. Sie können jetzt diesen Stolz in dieser Region nochmal erleben, hier wird noch alles versucht, um das zu erhalten. Aber sie müssen wirklich jetzt kommen. Jetzt gleich, schreibt er. Das ist ihm ganz wichtig. Denn sonst ist diese Helligkeit und die Wärme, die man hier vorfindet, einfach verloren. Sie ist dann nicht mehr in dieser Welt. Also wir sehen hier in Japan eine richtige Auflösungserscheinung. Es hört richtig Gesellschaft auf mit diesem Überalterungsprozess. Die Leute ziehen in die Stadt, da finden sie ihr Schicksal. Und diese Dörfer bleiben einfach zurück. Und das ist Ostdeutschland in 20 Jahren ungefähr. Die Sächsische Schweiz und so weiter. Wunderbare Landschaft. Man fährt dahin, man denkt dann, wieso gibt es hier keinen Tourismus? Wieso betreibt noch nicht noch jemand ein Hotel oder so? Aber es ist auch das Publikum nicht mehr da. Es sind nur noch einzelne Leute, die sich dann vornehmen. Ich wandere jetzt 20 Tage hier durch und so. Und ja, an diesem schönen, schönen Stück, als es wirklich auch wahnsinnig aussieht, also krasse Fotos und so weiter, kann man mal sehen, ja, dass dieses Ganze, es gibt ja so verschiedene Bücher, Empty Planet zum Beispiel, wo auch argumentiert wird, nein, wir werden wirklich weniger. Die Zäsur ist da gewesen, wir werden jetzt weniger, wir schrumpfen allgemein und das heißt, wir ziehen uns auch aus diesen ehemaligen kulturell so hoch bedeutenden Orten wirklich zurück und dann erobert sich die Natur das alles wieder zurück. In Japan kann man es jetzt so erleben.
Es sei denn, man würde sagen, man lässt Zuwanderung zu, aber da ist ja Japan ganz restriktiv.
Auch diese Zuwanderung würde nicht in diesen Dörfern landen, sondern die bleibt in den urbanen Zentren hängen, wo sie auch gefragt und dann angeworben wird. Ja, also wie soll man sagen, er schreibt ja einfach nur, das ist da so, wie es jetzt gerade ist. Wer es nochmal sehen will, muss jetzt kommen. Da steckt gar kein Rettungsgedanke oder sowas drin. Wir sind jetzt in diesem Moment der Geschichte, wo man das nochmal sehen kann. Jeder sollte es sich nochmal anschauen, aber dann ist es einfach vorbei. Und damit hat er auch schon abgeschlossen. Also es ist dann auch für ihn vorbei. Er hat jetzt zehn Jahre lang diese Wanderung da gemacht und nochmal zehn Jahre werden es nicht.
Wir kommen nochmal zum Krieg zurück, zu Jürgen Habermas, der zwei Seiten freigeräumt bekam, allerdings dann für vier Spalten in der Süddeutschen Zeitung. Der Artikel heißt Krieg und Empörung. Das ist etwas, womit sich Habermas auseinandersetzen will. Wir hatten es ja schon mal in einer regulären Folge besprochen. Habermas verfolgt die sozialen Medien ein bisschen. Er stellt fest, dass da wüste Geräusche artikuliert werden, fragt sich, was kann man dagegen tun?
Das ist hier nicht die Frage, aber er stellt doch fest, es gibt so eine eigenartige Empörung in den sozialen Medien. Und er sagt auch gleich, es sei doch so, dass es uns Ältere dabei mehr beeindrucken mag, was da jetzt auch so medial möglich ist, wie man vom Krieg berichten kann, als das bei den Jüngeren der Fall ist. Und dann schreibt Habermas ziemlich am Anfang schon, so wächst unter den Zuschauern im Westen die Beunruhigung mit jedem Toten, die Erschütterung mit jedem Ermordeten, die Empörung mit jedem Kriegsverbrechen und der Wunsch, auch etwas dagegen zu tun. Der rationale Hintergrund, vor dem diese Emotionen landesweit aufwallen, ist die selbstverständliche Parteinahme gegen Putin und eine russische Regierung, die einen massiven, völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg vom Zaune gebrochen haben und die mit ihrer systemisch menschenverachtenden Kriegsführung gegen das humanitäre Völkerrecht verstoßen. Das ist erstmal das, was Habermas ganz klar benennt und er lässt da auch keinen Zweifel dran. Nun aber stellt er fest, in Deutschland ist ein Schriller von Pressestimmen geschürter Meinungskampf über Art und Ausmaß der militärischen Hilfe für die bedrängte Ukraine ausgebrochen. Wer jetzt mit Habermas nicht so vertraut ist, dem sei gesagt, Habermas formuliert hier drastisch, wie man es sonst von ihm nicht kennt. Also Habermas ist jetzt nicht dafür bekannt für Zuspitzungen, Polemiken oder sonst etwas. Aber wenn Habermas das in dieser Art formuliert, dann heißt das was, dass der 93-jährige Philosoph hier doch ganz klar sagt, hier läuft irgendwas falsch. Diese Stimmen, die sind schrill. Und doch irritiert mich, schreibt er dann, mich, auch das ist ungewöhnlich für Habermas, dass er also nochmal auf sich selbst Bezug nimmt, ja. Und doch irritiert mich die Selbstgewissheit, mit der in Deutschland die moralisch entrüsteten Ankläger gegen einen reflektiert und zurückhaltend verfahrenen Bundesregierung auftreten. Seine Politik bringt der Bundeskanzler im Interview mit dem Spiegel auf den Punkt und dann sagt er nochmal ganz klar, wir kennen das, Scholz sagt, wir sehen natürlich, dass er alles mit großer Sorge und wir wollen dem Leid entgegentreten, aber wir müssen auch aufpassen, dass wir nicht unermessliches Leid für die ganze Welt produzieren. Habermas sagt, das sei eine vernünftige Position. Habermas hat hier einen Text verfasst, der sich ganz klar hinter diesen Scholzkurs stellt. Der Westen sagt nämlich Habermas, habe sich ja selbst die Hände gebunden. Der Westen hat gesagt, oder den NATO-Staaten, wir werden nicht Kriegspartei. Das hat beiden gesagt, das haben alle gesagt. Damit hat man also sich erst einmal die Hände gebunden. Was ist aber dann das, was wir da jetzt dazwischen erleben? Denn das heißt ja nicht einfach, wir legen die Hände in den Schoß. Zunächst mal ist da eine Gefahr zu bedenken. Erst einmal ist da ja, dass gegen eine Atommacht man einen Krieg nicht gewinnen kann. Das sagt Habermas hier nochmal deutlich. Und das haben wir ja auch schon verhandelt. Nun hat man versucht, diesen Atomkrieg, der so total ist, ein bisschen zu verkleinern, indem man kleinere Atomwaffen ja produziert hat, um punktuelle nukleare Angriffe zu starten. Aber dennoch will man das erstmal nicht. Aber es führt uns auch nicht davon weg, dass Russland in einem asymmetrischen Vorteil sich befindet. Und zwar schreibt Habermas, das Verleid der russischen Seite einen asymmetrischen Vorteil gegenüber der NATO, die wegen des apokalyptischen Ausmaßes eines Weltkrieges mit der Beteiligung von vier Atommächten nicht zu Kriegspartei werden will. Was bedeutet das nun? Also Russland kann natürlich den Krieg eskalieren lassen und wir können uns in gewisser Weise da immer nur defensiv zu verhalten, was nicht heißt, dass wir alle Zugeständnisse machen. Aber da Russland, wenn es sich bereit zeigt, eskalieren zu lassen, eskalieren kann, müssen wir besonders vorsichtig sein. Und wir können aber nicht einfach sagen, naja, die machen ja eh was sie wollen und deswegen können wir auch machen, was wir wollen, sondern wir müssen in gewisser Weise anerkennen, dass wo der Feind zu allem vielleicht fähig ist, wir besonders achtsam sein müssen, vorsichtig sein müssen. Und Habermas sagt es dann, nun entscheidet Putin darüber, wann der Westen die völkerrechtlich definierte Schwelle überschreitet. Das ist furchtbar, dass das so ist. Nur das meint auch nicht, weil das zum Teil falsch rezipiert wurde, Habermas sagt ja, wir müssen Putin gewähren lassen. Aber das sind einfach die Fakten, die da sind. Und die können wir auch mit gut zureden oder mit moralischen Argumentationen nicht hintergehen. Er stellt auch die Frage, inwieweit wir denn auch Kriegspartei sind in Form der Sanktionen. Also es ist ja gar nicht so, als würden wir uns raushalten, sondern es sei doch ein enormes Kriegsgeschehen, das davon statten geht, durch unsere Sanktionen und dass man das auch nicht gering schätzen sollte. Und dann kommt dieses große andere Seite, der Westen darf sich natürlich nicht erpressen lassen. Und das hat zwei Gründe. Einmal den moralischen Grund, dass man natürlich nicht sagen kann, ja, liebe Ukrainer, Pech gehabt. Wir werden uns da nicht die Hände schmutzig machen. Und zweitens, mit Blick auf die NATO, es ist natürlich auch geostrategisch geboten, in irgendeiner Weise etwas zu tun und das muss aber austariert werden. Es kann nicht sein, dass man dabei einfach nur Maximalforderungen formuliert und so tut, als gäbe es die anderen Gefahren nicht. Habermas schreibt, dabei geht es um die Beachtung einer aus unserer Sicht für Putin zustimmungsfähigen Interpretation einer rechtlich definierten Grenze, die wir uns selbst auferlegt haben. Also wir haben uns die Hände selbst gebunden, zu sagen, wir werden nicht Kriegspartei. Das ist auch ein souveräner Akt. Wir hoffen darauf, dass Putin unserer Grenzziehung schon zugestimmt hat und sagt, ah, okay, die werden ja nicht Kriegspartei. Und daran jetzt sein Handeln ausrichtet, dass er sagt, okay, wenn sie sich daran halten, dann halte ich mich auch daran, dass es keinen nuklearen Krieg gibt. Das ist das gegenseitige Versprechen unter Feinden, dass sich da quasi abgegeben wurde. Und deswegen muss man da sehr vorsichtig sein, wenn man das doch in irgendeiner Weise überschreitet. Aber ist es nicht ein frommer Selbstbetrug, fragt Habermas, auf einen Sieg der Ukraine gegen die mörderische russische Kriegsführung zu setzen, ohne selbst Waffen in die Hand zu nehmen? Die kriegstreiberische Rhetorik verträgt sich schlecht mit der Zuschauerloge, aus der sie wortstark ertönt. Denn sie entkräftet ja nicht die Unberechenbarkeit eines Gegners, der alles auf eine Karte setzen könnte. Das ist, glaube ich, auch etwas, was wir schon mal thematisiert haben. Wir sagen jetzt ja schwere Waffen und so, aber wir bleiben schon auf der Zuschauerloge und sagen, macht mal dann mit unseren schweren Waffen da. Und das ist eine moralisch schwierige Angelegenheit. Und da sagt er, es ist ein frommer Selbstbetrug. Also er stellt das als Frage, aber beantwortet die natürlich. Ist eine rhetorische Frage. Was will Putin? Habermas weiß es auch nicht. Wir werden nachher noch so einen Text haben. Er sagt, ist das hier das, was Alexander Dugin vorschlägt? Ich hatte da ja auch Clips zu dabei. Kann sein, kann aber auch sein, dass es einfach geopolitisches Kalkül ist. Denn Putin ist auch ein Mann, der im KGB Karriere gemacht hat, der geostrategisch geschult ist und so weiter. Das heißt, wir können durchaus vielleicht festmachen, dass wir es nicht wissen. Und das macht das Ganze noch viel komplizierter. Er wundert sich, Habermas, wie diese Debatten verlaufen. Er wundert sich, über das kurze Gedächtnis der heutigen Kontroversen wird eines Tages das Urteil der Historiker entscheiden. Auch ein sehr guter Satz, wo auch, glaube ich, nochmal dieser Generationenkonflikt deutlich wird, weil wir ja auch festgestellt haben, die Generation U40 ist es gerade, die besonders laut trommelt. Anders fällt es sich mit der Debatte, die sich unter dem bedeutungsträchtigen Namen einer neuen deutschen Identitätskrise schon jetzt mit den Konsequenzen der zunächst nüchtern auf die deutsche Ostpolitik und den Verteidigungshaushalt bezogenen Zeitenwende befasst. Es ist also diese Generation der Jüngeren, die da so ein Empfinden hat. Es heißt da, diese Lesart fixiert sich auf das Beispiel jener Jüngeren, die zur Empfindlichkeit in normativen Fragen erzogen worden sind, ihre Emotionen nicht verstecken und am lautesten ein stärkeres Engagement einfordern. Diese Empfindlichkeit, diese Kultur, die ja auch im Prinzip bei das Ende des Endes der Geschichte aufscheint, diese findet einen Ausdruck dann in der Person Baerbock, dass man sagt, also mit der identifizieren wir uns jetzt ganz stark, denn die empfindet das ja für uns mit. Aber da wissen wir natürlich auch, das ist ihre Aufgabe, das dann jetzt gerade so zu tun. Das ist ja auch mit Scholz abgestimmt. Aber was Habermas dann eigentlich ausmacht, ist, dass es neben diesem Krieg einen Mentalitätskonflikt gibt. Nämlich den zwischen Empfindung und Ratio. Die einen können sich einen Krieg nur unter der Alternative von Sieg oder Niederlage vorstellen. Die anderen wissen, dass Kriege gegen eine Atommacht nicht mehr im herkömmlichen Sinne gewonnen werden können. Das ist ja immer noch was, was mitspringt. Also, dass man noch glaubt, es wird dann so sein, dass die eine oder die andere Kriegspartei einfach die weiße Fahne hisst und dann ist Schluss. Nein, das ist selbstverständlich nicht der Fall. Er wundert sich auch, dass das Posteroische dann in gewisser Weise nicht mehr so stark da ist. Er zitiert dann Alexander Kluge, vom Krieg kann man nur lernen, Frieden zu machen. Und er spitzt es dann nochmal zu auf sein Alter und verstärkt nochmal diese Überraschung. Er diagnostiziert zunächst mal eine humanitäre Sensibilisierung in der Bevölkerung. Das ist ja auch erstmal nichts Schlechtes, dass man also empört ist darüber, was da passiert. Und dann sagt er, in meinem Alter verhehle ich nicht eine gewisse Überraschung. Wie tief muss der Boden der kulturellen Selbstverständlichkeiten, auf dem unsere Enkel, Kinder und Enkel heute leben, umgepflügt worden sein, wenn sogar die konservative Presse nach den Staatsanwälten eines internationalen Strafgerichtshofes ruft, der weder von Russland und China noch von den USA anerkannt wird? Leider verrät sich in solchen Realitäten auch der doch noch holklingende Boden einer erregten Identifizierung mit den immer schriller gewordenen moralischen Anklagen der deutschen Zurückhaltung. Nicht als hätte es der Kriegsverbrecher Putin nicht verdient, vor einem solchen Gericht zu stehen. Aber noch nimmt er im Sicherheitsrat der Vereinten Nationen den Sitz einer Vetum-Macht ein und kann seinen Gegnern mit Atomwaffen drohen. Noch muss mit ihm ein Ende des Krieges wenigstens ein Waffenstillstand verhandelt werden. Und das ist einfach nicht aus der Welt zu räumen. Wie er erleben, sagt er, politisch-mentale Differenzen. Also die, die da rational drüber sprechen wollen und die, die aber so sehr in ihren schrillen Tönen aus einer Empörung heraus gefangen sind. Und diese Konfusion, die muss gestoppt werden, damit– und da sind wir natürlich wieder bei einer deliberativen Demokratie, die auf Diskurs angewiesen ist, damit ein Diskurs möglich ist. Aber wie ist denn das jetzt mit dem Mitgefühl und der Empörung? Alexander Kluge hat ja auch gesagt, na, ich fühle da schon mit, aber da ist auch noch das andere. Und Habermas bringt es nochmal wunderschön auf den Punkt, dieses Verhältnis von Gefühlen zur Moral und Ratio. Er sagt, gewiss, ohne moralische Gefühle keine moralischen Urteile. Aber das verallgemeinernde Urteil korrigiert auch seinerseits die beschränkte Reichweite der aus der Nähe stimulierten Gefühle. Erst dann, ich will es nochmal wiederholen, gewiss, ohne moralischen Gefühle keine moralischen Urteile. Also ich muss erstmal moralisch empfinden, das geht nicht, dass die Russen die Ukrainer tot schießen. Aber das verallgemeinernde Urteil, also da, wo dann die Ratio mit reinkommt, korrigiert auch seinerseits die beschränkte Reichweite der aus der Nähe stimulierten Gefühle. Das heißt, ich kann nicht nur sagen, jetzt müssen wir alles tun. Habt ihr das gesehen? Und das ist nicht nur eine Erkennung von Gefühlen, sondern auch eine Erkennung von Gefühlen, die sich auf der Ebene, wo die Ratio hinzukommt, natürlich auch erkennen, dass ich diese Affekte, die ich da habe, wiederum in einen solchen Rahmen bringe, dass ein genereller Friede bestehen bleibt und es nicht zu einer Eskalation kommt. Und Habermas greift hier ganz zum Schluss dann nochmal diesen Gedanken auf der europäischen Armee, für die er sich ja schon sehr stark ausgesprochen hat vor Jahren. Es gab da auch mal gemeinsam mit auch konservativen Politikern zum Teil einen Artikel im Handelsblatt, hat damals schon eigentlich verwundert, dass Habermas da mitmacht, aber das scheint ihm sehr wichtig. Und er schreibt dann noch ziemlich gegen Ende, Macron's Wiederwahl markiert eine Galgenfrist.
Also wir hatten ja in Europa mal diese Idee der KSZE, die ist natürlich immer noch da. Konferenz für Sicherheit und Zusammenarbeit in Europa. Jetzt heißt sie, glaube ich, OSZE oder wie auch immer, aber es gab ja zur der NATO alternative Bündnisse, die Amerika ein bisschen außen vor lassen. Und dann im Hintergrund eben dieses Gerangel, er war ohne amerikanische Vormachtstellung und so weiter, bis hin zu der misslichen Lage, dass wir uns heute quasi nicht verteidigen. Und das heißt vor allem, nicht drohen können uns zu verteidigen, außer die Amerikaner machen mit. Finde ich sehr gut von Habermas. Der Spiegel hat gestern auch noch mal einen Text gehabt darüber, wie ukrainische Männer gezwungen werden in diesen Krieg, dass das nicht alles Heldentum und Freiwilligkeit ist und so, sondern dass gerade da im Osten jetzt sehr viele einfach hingeschickt werden in den Krieg. Und sehr viele zurückgelassen Familien dann eben da auch versuchen, mit Protestnoten oder wie auch immer Kontra zu geben.
Verlink den doch mal bitte mit, dass wir den auch noch lesen können.
Genau, also dieser Spiegeltext und naja, was soll man sagen? Es ist halt Habermas, diese politischen Kommentierungen sind sehr gut und sehr wichtig. Mir ist jedenfalls nicht aufgefallen, dass man gegen Habermas jetzt so rumgeschossen hätte, wie gegen die Autoren des offenen Briefs.
Nee, das hat man sich dann doch nicht getraut. Also das ist dann vielleicht ein Kaliber zu viel und ich sag mal, wenn man den, also manche haben dann zum Teil polemisieren wollen, aber dann eigentlich auch zu wenig verstanden von dem Text.
Genau, das Habermas selber noch mal auf den Wirtschaftskrieg zu sprechen kommt, finde ich sehr gut, denn das kommt wie immer zu kurz. Wir führen gerade auch einen Wirtschaftskrieg gegen Russland, der dort auch nicht folgenlos bleibt, um das mal so zu sagen und der auch nicht endet mit, je nachdem wie das in der Ukraine endet, sondern das bleibt ja erst mal so bestehen.
Dann werden wir vielleicht in 20 Jahren dann mal sagen, oh jetzt beginnt so eine neue Annäherungspolitik oder so.
Ja, genau. Es ist kritisch, es sei denn man kriegt das über das Personal irgendwie schneller organisiert, aber dann muss man auch erstmal Putin irgendwie beseitigen, keine Ahnung wie sowas vonstatten gehen soll. Alexander Kluge hat ja noch mal darauf hingewiesen, dass es die Einsicht in die Schwäche ist, die einen Frieden ermöglicht. Diese Einsicht wollen wir uns ja partout nicht geben. Da hat ja auch Habermas jetzt gute Worte für gefunden. Und sei es nur die Selbstermächtigung über irgendwelche Tweets oder so, dass man sich da in so einer Position der Stärke sieht und einfach nur mit mobilisieren möchte. Dieser Verweis auf die Rufe nach dem handelnden Staat. Vielleicht doppelt sich das jetzt mit Corona. Diese These von Matthias. Wir haben jetzt drei Jahre lang gesehen, wie der Staat nicht eingreift beim Thema Klima. Dann haben wir bei Corona gesehen, wie sehr er handeln kann und jetzt fordern wir das einfach auch. Aber da ist halt einfach nur eine Transferleistung. Wir haben es erlebt, dass der Staat handeln kann. Die Folgenabschätzung haben wir aber nicht mit. Also die macht ja gerade keiner. So und dann hat man so komische Tagesthemen, Kommentare wie von der Gierschick. Also der Verweis auf einen Atomkrieg verhindern reicht mir nicht, hat sie ja so gesagt. Und das ist natürlich dann wirklich hanebüchener, so was vor Millionen Publikum dann zu senden.
Naja, das kann ich ja auch sagen, wie Zigaretten verursachen Dungenkrebs. Also das finde ich jetzt aber kein probates Argument.
Ja, es ist wirklich wahnsinnig komisch. Na gut, sehr gut, Habermas. Mal gucken, wie viel er uns da noch aushelfen kann beim Denken, kollektiven Denken. Bleiben wir mal in dieser geopolitischen Sackgasse, Reihe zu digitalem Kolonialismus, wie Meta in den indischen Agrarsektor dominieren will. Der indische Agrarsektor, also wir reden über einen Milliardenvolk, da scheint es sehr viel Agrarnotwendigkeit zu geben. netzpolitik.org, Satyajit Malik. Datenkolonialisierung ist im Grunde wie früher die Kolonialisierung, nur jetzt eben mit Daten und wir kennen ja die Geschichte. Ein großer indischer CEO und zwar von dem Unternehmen Reliance, nee Reliance, nein wie auch immer, Reliance Industries hat sich 2018 wie folgt geäußert, Indiens Daten müssen von der indischen Bevölkerung kontrolliert werden und in ihrem Besitz sein und nicht in Besitz von globalen Konzernen. Das richtete sich gegen Facebook und die damals mit dieser, ihr könnt das Internet kostenlos haben, also wir übernehmen die Kosten, solange ihr nur Facebook benutzt und so weiter, gescheitert sind und nur zwei Jahre später, 2020, gab das gleiche Unternehmen, Reliance Industries, grünes Licht für einen Deal mit Facebook. Wie konnte das passieren? Wir haben es hier bei einer Partnerschaft zwischen zwei Unternehmen zu tun, die also die ganze Lebensmittelversorgungskette monopolisieren könnte und damit auch die Ernährungssicherheit Indiens gefährden. Reliance Industries gilt häufig so als das Rockefellers von Indien. Man hat Monopole in einigen Schlüsselbereichen der Wirtschaft. Man ist zum Beispiel größter Telekommunikationsanbieter, was hier bedeutet 428 Millionen Nutzer. Also da wird vielleicht richtig groß gedacht. Einer der größeren Akteure im Einzelhandelssektor mit Reliance Geomart, eine Online-Lebensmittelplattform in Betrieb, die einen gehörigen Anteil am insgesamt 900 Milliarden Dollar schweren Einzelhandelsmarkt in Indien hat. Und die wiederum, also diese Tochterfirma, hat eine App GeoCrisci, mit der sie vermitteln, Daten gestützt zwischen den Landwirtschaftsproduzenten und dann den Verkäufern, um beispielsweise zu koordinieren, was wird überhaupt angebaut. Also es wird hier eine ganz große Datenanalyse für die ganz großen Fragestellungen gemacht. Und dann kam WhatsApp und wollte WhatsApp Pay einführen. Da gab es aber noch einige Hindernisse, datenschutzrechtlich und so weiter. Facebook scheiterte also nach dieser allgemeinen, wir wollen ja mal Facebook für alle kostenlos machen, auch mit WhatsApp Pay bis Facebook im April 2020 9,9 Prozent von Reliance Gio, also diesem sparten Tochterunternehmen für den Einzelhandel, gekauft hat für 5,7 Milliarden Dollar. Also da sieht man schon, um wie viel Geld es hier insgesamt geht. Das Unternehmen hat so 50 Milliarden Wert. Und plötzlich hieß es dann, Facebook hat jetzt doch eine Erlaubnis um sein WhatsApp Pay Bezahlsystem. Kennen wir ja so ein bisschen. Man kann auch in London immer noch Wohnungen kaufen, wenn man nur bereit ist, grundsätzlich zu investieren in das Land, dann kriegt man ja ganz schnell so quasi Staatsbürgerrechte. Und so ist das hier wirtschaftlich eben auch. Und Facebook hat dann relativ schnell begonnen.
Zumal Indien ja eh einen Kampf gegen das Bargeld seit Jahren führt.
Richtig, genau.
Das ist da bestimmt ganz gut mit voran, wenn man da nochmal ein eigenes Angebot liefert.
Genau, also die haben eine riesige Nutzerbasis, 500 Millionen WhatsApp-Nutzer in Indien. Und die konnten jetzt alle plötzlich Geschäftskredite entgegennehmen. 12.300 Euro in fünf Minuten, das sind so die Versprechen. Die Kreditlaufzeit beträgt zwischen 6 und 48 Monaten. Also man konnte sich da relativ zügig mit Geld versorgen. Und naja, der Text schwenkt dann kurz um, wie Facebook grundsätzlich den Süden der Welt so ein bisschen ummodeln möchte. In 29 Ländern der Welt sind sie vertreten mit diesen verschiedenen Projekten und Produkten. Und Indien ist wie Vishal Shah, die Leiterin der Produktabteilung für Metaverse, schreibt ein Schlüsselmarkt für auch alle künftigen Metaverse-Produkte. Denn 500 Millionen WhatsApp-Nutzer, 350 Millionen Facebook-Nutzer, Instagram spielt da auch noch eine gehörige Rolle. Also man hat da einfach mit einem erheblichen, um nicht zu sagen, so 10, 20, 25 Prozent von Facebook ist einfach indisch, wenn die heute mit ihren drei Milliarden Nutzern kommen und so weiter. Und diese Integration von Joycrisci, dieser App von JoyMart mit WhatsApp Pay, ist nun der Türöffner, um grundsätzlich Zugang zu haben zu allen, die Lebensmittel herstellen und vertreiben und die dann mit finanziellen Produkten ausstatten zu können. Da ist man ja dann, wenn sowas als Projekt einmal läuft, ziemlich tief drin, denn die ganzen kleineren Produzenten, die es natürlich auch gibt, wenn die da einfach an so einem großen Markt partizipieren können, indem sie einfach WhatsApp und WhatsApp Pay herunterladen, also gleichzeitig Geld bekommen und noch inhaltliche Hinweise, was lohnt sich denn jetzt anzubauen und so weiter. Dann ist man ja schnell mal in so einer, dann investiere ich jetzt mal in dieses und jenes und hol mir dann nächstes Jahr die Erträge. Also da ist man jetzt in Indien richtig drin und macht es vor allem über die Kreditvergabe. Erstaunlicherweise gab es dagegen Protest. Und zwar nicht nur in Indien selber. 250 Millionen Menschen haben sich beteiligt. Also es gilt als einer der größten Proteste der Weltgeschichte, grundsätzlich gegen Facebook. Sondern es gab auch Proteste in Menlo Park, also am Hauptsitz von Facebook in Amerika. Man konnte tatsächlich krass mobilisieren, was ja auch zeigt, in welchem Rahmen sich das hier abspielt. Aber der Text kann dann leider nur mit der Befürchtung schließen, dass hier versucht wird, einen Privatisierungsplan umzusetzen, der sobald sich die Wut gelegt hat, dann wirklich ganz Indien da auch links kreppelt. Also es geht um Milliarden und Milliarden, um nicht zu sagen Billionenmärkte. Und Facebook ist da tief drin. Ich möchte diesen Text empfehlen und grundsätzlich diese Reihe, also netzpolitik.org sowieso, aber auch scheint mir eine gute Idee zu sein, diesen digitalen Kolonialismus einmal so aufzubereiten, dass man hier vielleicht auch Unterrichtsmaterialien findet für den einen oder anderen Wirtschaftsstunden, die man mal macht.
Und Zuckerberg muss sich dann vielleicht gar nicht mehr so sehr fürchten vor dem, was in der EU geschieht, wenn man da einfach mehr als eine Milliarde Menschen erreichen kann.
Das stimmt. Also da macht man so viele kleine Umsätze, dass es reicht, um vielleicht so eine ganze Europäische Union, die man nun echt nur mit Werbemarkt erreicht. Alle anderen Marktzugänge sind ja da erst mal so ein bisschen beschränkter. In so gesättigten Märkten kann man dann einfach links liegen lassen fast.
Timofay Sergejzew ist einer der angeblichen Chefideologen in Russland, der publizistisch Futter liefert für diesen Krieg, der aber auch einen Text geschrieben hat, was Russland mit der Ukraine tun sollte. Also was geschieht, wenn Russland die Ukraine eingenommen hat. Und das ist ein Text, der dokumentiert ist in den Blättern und der einem das Fürchten lehrt. Denn das ist ganz erstaunlich, was hier eigentlich geschrieben wird. Wir haben ja diese Rede noch ein bisschen im Ohr von Putin, diese Eigenartige, wo er da wie in so einer Hotellobby saß und ein bisschen erzählte, wie er die Geschichte versteht und dann meinte, wir müssten die Ukraine entnazifizieren. Und man ist erst einmal so aufgeschreckt und denkt, wie entnazifizieren, was meint er denn da eigentlich? Und das wird jetzt in diesem Text ein bisschen klarer oder klarer ist schon so viel gesagt, aber man sieht zumindest jetzt dieses ideologische Spektrum, in dem sich das bewegt ein bisschen besser. Da heißt es, die Entnazifizierung besteht aus einer Reihe von Maßnahmen, gegenüber der nazifizierten Masse der Bevölkerung, die technisch gesehen nicht direkt als Kriegsverbrecher bestraft werden kann. Also man glaubt jetzt, die größten Teile der ukrainischen Bevölkerung, die müssen entnazifiziert werden. Nazis, die zu den Waffen gegriffen haben, sollten auf dem Schlachtfeld so weit wie möglich vernichtet werden, heißt es in dem Text. Es sollte kein signifikanter Unterschied gemacht werden zwischen der ukrainischen Armee und den so genannten nationalen Bataillonen, sowie den Milizen zur territorialen Verteidigung. Also martialische Worte, die martialische Taten rechtfertigen sollen. Es ist die Rede hier von einem gerechten Krieg gegen das narzisstische System. Der Zeitrahmen, also für das, was dann der Ukraine blüht, wenn Russen sie jetzt komplett besetzt hätte, sieht wie folgt aus. Der Zeitrahmen für die Endnazifisierung kann auf keinen Fall kürzer sein, als eine Generation, die unter den Bedingungen der Endnazifisierung geboren, herangewachsen und reifen muss. Die Nazifisierung der Ukraine hat über 30 Jahre gedauert, mindestens seit 1989, als der ukrainische Nationalismus legal und digitime Formen des politischen Ausdrucks erhielt und die Bewegung für die Unabhängigkeit in Richtung Narzissmus führte. So, jetzt sind wir maximal verwirrt, weil wir die ganze Zeit denken, was ist denn jetzt mit Nazi gemeint? Weil wir natürlich an Nationalsozialismus denken, wir denken an einen Antisemitismus, der zu einer Vernichtung der Juden führte. Und interessanterweise kommt das aber, Antisemitismus, Juden überhaupt nicht vor in diesem Text. Und man denkt, ja, aber ihr schreibt doch hier über die Entnazifizierung. Was ist denn das eigentlich hier? Und dann heißt es, die Besonderheit der heutigen nazifizierten Ukraine ist ihr amorfer und ambivalenter Charakter, der es ermöglicht, den Narzissmus als Bestreben nach Unabhängigkeit und einem europäischen Weg der Entwicklung zu tarnen und zu behaupten, dass es in der Ukraine keinen Narzissmus gibt, sondern nur private, sporadische Exzesse. Also was hier schon mal getan wird, ist, man löst den Begriff Narzissmus vom Nationalsozialismus und von all dem, was damit verbunden ist, bleibt nur eigentlich so ein Slogan übrig von Entnazifizierung, die dringend vonstattengehen muss. Aber es ist losgelöst von dem, was eigentlich Nationalsozialismus mal bedeutete. Und so lässt sich das dann ganz einfach aufhopfen und alles als narzisstisch frameen, was einem nicht gelegen ist. Zum Beispiel, dass die Ukraine sich gerne ein bisschen mehr nach Europa ausrichten würde. Es gibt keine führende Nazi-Partei, heißt es dann dem Text auch. Kein Führer, keine vollwertigen Rassengesetze. Es wird dann auch von einer abgespeckten Version gesprochen, die betreffe jene, die die russische Sprache sprechen. Infolgedessen gibt es keine Opposition und keinen Widerstand gegen das Regime. Also was hier noch mal ausgedrückt wird ist, gerade weil es keinen Führer, keine Partei gibt, gibt es nicht keine Nazis, sondern es gibt deswegen noch nicht mal eine Opposition gegen die Nazis, weil eigentlich das ganze Land in irgendeiner Weise entnazifiziert werden muss. Das ist, es ist sehr absurd. Ich bin aber trotzdem dankbar, dass man das hier einmal dokumentiert. Denn was hier deutlich wird, ist, es wird hier ein ideologischer Rahmen gesetzt für diesen Angriffskrieg von Putin, der aber auch, glaube ich, nur ein Sinnangebot darstellt für manche Russen. Also das ist einfach, ich formuliere hier mal ein Sinnangebot. Ihr könnt gerne darauf zugreifen, wenn ihr aber gerne noch das andere Sinnangebot haben wollt, das Putin ja früher viel häufiger hervorbrachte. Wir werden bedroht durch die NATO-Osterweiterung. Ihr könnt dieses Sinnangebot auch haben. Ich kann euch aber auch noch weitere Sinnangebote zur Verfügung stellen. Es ist eigentlich egal. In gewisser Weise ist es fast ein postmoderner Umgang mit Geschichte, mit Geopolitik, dass man sagt, wir schauen mal, was hier sich eigentlich anbietet. Die Endnazifizierung heißt, es wird unweigerlich eine End-Ukranisierung sein. Also da sehen wir natürlich, dass das so weit formuliert ist, dass da alles denkbar ist. Deshalb natürlich, wenn jetzt solche Forderungen kommen, wie dass wir jetzt dringend Frieden brauchen oder dass die Ukraine den Krieg nicht gewinnen kann, man auf jeden Fall die Flöcke einschlagen muss, dass genau so was nicht da stattfinden kann. Also das ist genau das dann, was in diesen wahrscheinlich sehr schwierig werdenden Verhandlungen vonstatten gehen muss, dass nicht in irgendeiner Weise ein Morden dort in einem neuen rechtlichen Rahmen beginnen kann. Also dass man nicht da den Rahmen setzt für einen permanenten Völkerrechtsbruch, sondern dass genau die, die hier als Feinde, als Nazis beschrieben werden, davor geschützt werden. Und dass wir eine Friedensordnung brauchen, die nicht diese Art der Diskriminierung des ukrainischen Volkes bedeuten kann, was ja am Ende Tür und Tor für einen Völkermord tatsächlich öffnen kann.
Also wenn man solche Ideologien, sagen wir mal so, du vor allem behandelt ja Ideologien vor allem wegen ihrer inhaltlichen Gefährlichkeit, so sanftmütig sie auch immer hervorkommen. Wenn wir jetzt solche Texte haben, die sozusagen Ideologie nur so als leeres Gefäß hinstellen, wo am Ende jeder seinen Deutungsmüll irgendwie reinwerfen kann, du hast ja so als Sinnangebot, also wo sozusagen Brandbreite da ist und man sich nicht mal genaue Gedanken darüber macht, was ist jetzt mit Nazis gemeint, wenn ich eine Entnazifizierung mit Waffengewalt schon durchsetze? Dann sind wir ja an so einem Punkt, wo wir im kleinen Rahmen das in Fake Facts bei Katharina Nockhun und Pia Lamberti nachlesen können, mit dem Verweis auf, naja Leute, wenn wir es mit solchen Verblendungen und Kommunikation zu tun haben, dann versucht nicht inhaltlich dagegen zu argumentieren, sondern gestaltet das Gespräch auf der Beziehungsebene, führt einen gewissen Rhythmus ein, führt die Leute zurück in Sozialität, in Gesellschaft, in Gemeinschaft und so weiter, aber verbrennt euch nicht die Finger an Inhalten. Und das scheint mir hier auch ganz dringend geboten zu sein, dass wir solche Texte nicht aufgreifen politisch und uns dann freuen, dass es das nächste Mal ein zwei Stunden, zehn Minuten langes Telefonat mit Joe Biden gab oder so, sondern dass man oder mit Macron jetzt kürzlich, sondern dass man dann einfach sagt, jemand hat mit Putin gesprochen, sehr gut, Hauptsache nicht über den Krieg. Also irgendwie so, dass man jetzt mal ganz in die Ecke denkt.
Also hier diese Diskussion, du hast vollkommen recht, kann man sich nicht einlassen. Wir haben das im Sommer erlebt mit dieser Jana aus Kassel, die sich dann mit, ich glaube, Anne Frank verglichen hat, weil sie Maske tragen muss oder so. Oder mit soviel Scholl. Und das kann man jetzt so übertragen. Also in diesem Text heißt es dann folgendes. Diese wiederum, also, Nazifizierung sollte mit der Organisation der lokalen Selbstverwaltung, der Polizei, der Verteidigung beginnen, die von narzisstischen Elementen gesäubert werden muss. Dann heißt es, dass es einen republikanischen Regelungsrahmen geben muss für die Entnazifizierung unter russischer Kontrolle, wobei die Grenzen und der Rahmen direkt festgelegt werden. In dieser Hinsicht sollte Russland als Hüter der Nürnberger Prozesse auftreten.
Ja, was ist denn dagegen?
Da kann man jetzt nicht sagen, wir müssen noch mal über die Geschichte reden oder so. Das geht einfach nicht mehr. Sondern das ist dann einfach nur noch der Punkt, wo man das als Warnung zur Kenntnis nehmen muss, um wirklich die ukrainische Bevölkerung davor zu bewahren. Und das bedeutet zur Not auch zu sagen, ihr könnt alle kommen. Und auf der anderen Seite heißt es aber auch, das kann keine Art der Debatte werden, die man führen kann mit Putin oder so. Man kann nur bei Friedensverhandlungen einen Rahmen setzen, wo das einfach solche Konzepte niemals umgesetzt werden können. Weil dann wirklich Eskalation droht. Das ist die einzige Möglichkeit. Aber es ist, wenn man mal in diese doch Fan-Fiction der grausamsten Weise eintreten will, eine ganz gute Dokumentation.
Oh, weil zurück zu unseren Problemen, das Bauen. Ein wahnsinnig gutes Interview mit einem anscheinend wirklich coolen Typen, Werner Sobek, Bauingenieur. Die Welt hat er ausführlich sehr lange mit ihm gesprochen. Ich kenne die Printversion nicht, aber das scheint mir so ein Wochenend-Doppelseiten-Ding zu sein. Also gigantisch. Und er wird uns vorgestellt als Gründungsmitglied der Deutschen Gesellschaft für nachhaltiges Bauen. Er baut statt Passivhäuser Aktivhäuser. Was ist damit gemeint? Naja, er ist auf der Suche nach dem emissionsfreien Gebäude, weiß auch, wie es geht. Er will die elektrische Stadt. Dafür verweist er auch auf Mobilität. Und er hat jetzt eine Trilogie bzw. in den ersten Band eine Trilogie vorgestellt. Non nobis über das Bauen der Zukunft. Angesichts der Erderwärmung und der ambitionierten Klimaziele der Europäischen Union mahnt er zu einem radikalen Umdenken, bevor es zu spät ist. Und er betont, wir können nicht mehr so bauen, wie wir die letzten 30 Jahre eingebaut haben. Wir brauchen einen neuen Materialeinsatz. Vor allem minimieren. Wir brauchen weniger Material. Mehr recycelinggerecht konstruieren. Also dass wir jetzt schon so bauen, dass wir es dann wieder recyceln können in 50 oder 100 Jahren. Und wir müssen diese Emissionen betrachten, insbesondere bei der Herstellung der Gebäude. Das ist ja so wichtig. Während es jetzt bei dem Wohnbautag, da wurde auch nicht darüber gesprochen, sondern beim Betrieb der Gebäude. Da gelten die ganzen Gesetze fürs Bauen selbst. Das gilt noch fast gar nichts. Und das ist ein ernsthaftes Problem. Wie haben wir uns denn in diese Probleme herein manövriert? Na, durch Nichtstun und durch Verdrängung. Sehr viele große Bauunternehmen, da fand ja auch so eine gewisse Konsolidierung des Marktes statt, haben gar keine eigenen Forschungsabteilungen. Die universitäre Forschung gibt es so auch nicht. Er selbst lehrt seit 1992 und hat seitdem auch eine Vorlesungsreihe übers recyclengerechte Bauen, also recyclengerechte Architektur, wie er das nennt. Die Wiederverwendung der Dinge erscheint ihm, ist ihm das Allerwichtigste und trotzdem wurde dieses Thema vernachlässigt. Die Architektur-Fakultäten kennen nur den Neubau, kritisiert er. Also da sitzt man einfach da und errechnet, was man auf leerem Boden so bauen könnte. Und dann kauft man halt einfach die Materialien, aber man plant nicht wirklich in einer Stadt, in der ja schon sehr viel Baumaterial ist, einfach mal umzubauen und dann auch mit dem vorhandenen Zeug zu bauen. Wir brauchen also auch in der Lehre einen behutsamen Ab- und Rückbau als Leereinhalt. In der Architektur und im Bauingenieurswesen, das findet er eh doof, dass es so auseinandergeht. Warum sind die Architekten da und die Bauingenieure da? Die müssten noch eigentlich zusammen einen Ausbildungspfad durchlaufen, um dann eben auch miteinander klarzukommen. Aber da zeigten sich die Hochschulen besonders unbeweglich. Und das findet er auch blöd. Es fehlt am Willen zur Veränderung. Und Non Nobles ist der Titel einer Rede von Cicero. Wir sind nicht für uns allein geboren und wir handeln nicht für uns allein. Das soll der neue Grundsatz sein. Also an die Zukunft denken. Die jungen Generationen, denen ist auch das Buch gewidmet. Das erste ist nun da. Es ist die Bestandsaufnahme. Das zweite Buch, das kommen wird, ist die verbleibenden Handlungskorridore einmal abschätzen. Und dann nutzen und das dritte Buch, das kommt, ist die neue Welt. Also es wird sich mit der neuen Welt befassen. Umwertung aller Werte. Er kommt über Nietzsche.
Toll, dass da jemand noch mal so einen großen Abwurf machen will.
Er macht auch die ganz große Philosophie runter über Nietzsche und so weiter. Er hat 17 Thesen, die er dann da und da beginnt das Interview dann erst so richtig interessant zu werden. Denn er sagt, die Natur ist das Maß aller Dinge. Sie ist das Allerwichtigste. Wir müssen zuerst einmal aufhören, in unseren Kellern Öl, Gas, Kohle und Holz zu verbrennen. Wir brauchen 650.000 neue Heizungen pro Jahr. Wir haben ja schon mal hier gehört, wie die Bauindustrie vielleicht so schafft, die Hälfte pro Jahr zu erneuern. Und er weiß auch, das ist für die Heizungs- und Sanitätsgewerbe nicht leistbar. Oder, und hier geht es dann los, wir gestehen jedem Menschen nur noch ein CO2-Emissionsbudget zu und gehen das dann auch konsequent an. Wir wiederverwerten alles, was im Hause anfällt. Auch warmes Wasser wird niemals einfach so weggeleitet, sondern damit dann wird dann einfach weitergewehrt. Wir duschen morgens, gleichzeitig läuft die Waschmaschine und wir führen zweimal warmes Wasser ab und so weiter. Wir brauchen hier eine nachhaltige neue Politik. Nicht nur, nicht für die Politik, sondern für eine soziale, stabile Gesellschaft, für das Überleben selbst. Energie nicht mehr über Verbrennungsprozesse bereitstellen. Das ist zum Beispiel einer dieser großen Tenor, Motti oder wie auch immer, den er da nennt. Und wir müssen aufhören, Beton zu verteufeln. Ja, wir brauchen weniger Beton und der Sand und der Kies, der geht auch wirklich zur Neige. Wir kennen ja schon diese ganze Sandmafia, die da Inseln abbuddelt. Wir brauchen Abbruchbeton. Das Problem ist, bis in die 60er Jahre wurden Häuser gebaut, die man gut wiederverwerten kann. Danach wurde alles möglich in den Beton reingemacht, um da irgendwelche Spezialkonstruktionen zu machen. Also da müsste man nochmal eine neue Recycling-Idee auch entwickeln. Da fehlt es an Forschung. Und dann schreibt er hier, und das fand ich hochinteressant, Beton nimmt im Laufe seiner Lebenszeit Kohlendioxid aus der Atmosphäre auf. Wenn er der Luft ausgesetzt ist und wir sie nicht mit Dämmplatten und so weiter, sondern luftumspülter Beton, ist für ihn so, das sollte man mal wieder häufiger machen. Dann haben wir es mit einer, es ist die Carbonatisierung des Betons, der da abläuft. Innerhalb von 20 Jahren kann Beton 95 Prozent des ursprünglich emittierten Kohlendioxid bei der Herstellung wieder aufnehmen. Wie so ein Baum. Also der saugt das einfach auf. Das ist ganz erstaunlich. Bei Stahl so ein bisschen das Gleiche. Kann nicht Dings aufnehmen, aber Stahl lässt sich sehr gut recyceln, sagt er. Also Stahl kann man immer rausisolieren, wenn es einmal verbaut ist. Einfach durch erhitzen und dann kann man den wiederverwenden. Und dann Holz. Jeder liebt Holz, aber es ist nicht so nachhaltig, wie wir glauben. Der Baum muss im Wald stehen bleiben, sagt er ganz deutlich. Und insbesondere, wenn wir höher als vier Stockwerke bauen und das Holz dann ums Feuer festzumachen mit Gipsplatten abbinden und so weiter, dann ist weder im Hause der Charme des Holzes zu sehen oder zu riechen, noch hat man sonst irgendwas davon. Also wenn schon Holz, dann richtig Holz, aber da wird viel Blödsinn gemacht und da sind auch die Regeln in Deutschland viel zu scharf, sagt er. Man sollte durchaus mal ein bisschen lockerer bauen. Wir brauchen andere Zementherstellung und Lehm und Naturstein und alles solche Sachen müssen wir uns noch erschließen. Warum wir alle immer nur im Standard-Sechsfamilien-Satteldach-Haus leben, kann er nicht verstehen. Hier braucht es auch altersgerecht neues Wohnen und dann spricht er ab, da im Interview, wahrscheinlich auch in seinen Büchern, immer nur von gebauter Umwelt. Wir bauen uns keine Häuser oder so, sondern wir bauen uns Umwelt. Wenn schon Umwelt da ist, wird hier integriert. Hier werden keine Bäume gefällt oder so, sondern er redet dann nur noch von gebauter Umwelt. Intergenerationales Wohnen, kurze Wege, bessere soziale Vernetzung, der ganze Kram und weg mit diesem Wärmeschutz, Brandschutz, Schallschutz-Irrsinn, sagt er. Es kostet so viel Material, ein Haus wirklich Schall zu isolieren. Aus einer 20-17 Zentimeter Wand wird dann eine 36 Zentimeter Wand und so weiter. Und es lohnt sich einfach alles nicht. Also ihr seht uns da auf einem ganz großen Irrweg. Und hier einmal vorgestellt, dass man das wirklich in diesen Büchern jetzt auch nachlesen kann. Also es gibt ja durchaus jetzt einen Anker, an dem man sich mal dranhängen kann, um solche Sachen. Und besonders gut gefällt mir das Finale. Ästhetik, ganz wichtig. Ästhetik, auch eine nachhaltige Strategie. Aber ja, sagt er. Und der allerletzte Satz, weil es ja dann heißt, ja, wir brauchen noch viel mehr Gebäude und wir haben zu wenig Geld und überhaupt und so. Und dann schreibt er, der letzte Satz dieses Interviews lautet, wenn die Kosten drücken, dann ist ein Reichtum an Fantasie gefragt. Das ist natürlich sehr schön. Ja, also in der Ansicht, das scheint mir ein Typ zu sein, der es nochmal drauf anlegt jetzt. Werner Sobek, S-O-B-E-K.
Einen Liebesroman möchte ich empfehlen. Ganz kurz will ich es machen. Der Roman heißt Lamento und ist verfasst von Madame Nielsen. Madame Nielsen ist eine außergewöhnliche Schriftstellerin, seit einer Weile auch in Deutschland bekannt. Ursprünglich hatten wir es mit einem Mann zu tun, der aber schon als Künstler tätig war, der dann eines Tages die Familie verließ, auf der Straße eine Weile lebte und sich dann neu erfand und verwandelte und nun als Frau auftritt, als Madame Nielsen und wunderbare Romane verfasst so. Auch dieses Mal ist es ein Liebesroman, bei dem ein Mann auf eine Frau trifft und sie verlieben sich. Beide sind sie in Künstlerkreisen zu Hause und das tolle ist, dass Madame Nielsen es schafft, diesen Rausch der Liebe zu beschreiben, dass sie eine unglaublich lebendige Sprache dafür hat. Da heißt es beispielsweise, und auf einmal sind wir ganz still und langsam ineinander hinein und klammern uns an den Abgrund des anderen und spüren die Verliebtheit ansteigen wie ein Fieber und stehen wieder in Brand. Wir liebten uns, ohne es können zu müssen und wir waren nicht gut darin und das war das Beste von allem. Wir hielten eine billige Kamera hoch und richteten sie auf das einzige, was wir wissen mussten. Wer sind wir? Und nahmen einen Augenblick aus der Zeit und ich hab ihn noch und das ist alles, was übrig ist und du. Denn wie so große Lieben beginnen mit viel Gefühl, so enden sie auch dann oft dramatisch oder zumindest auch wieder mit vielen Gefühlen und darum geht es natürlich auch um eine Liebe, die anschwillt, die versucht von der Verliebtheit in die Liebe überzugehen, die versucht auch dieses unbedingte Gefühl in den Alltag zu überführen, was schnell an Grenzen kommt und dann gibt es natürlich auch das unvermeidliche, die Trennung. Es ist ein Roman, der sehr sprunghaft diese Sache erzählt, also wir haben hier jetzt nicht einfach nur Lineargeschichte, sondern wir haben eine Autorin, die ihrem Kind oder eine Ich-Erzählerin, die ihrem Kind erzählt, wie diese Liebe, aus der dieses Kind auch stammt, zustande gekommen ist und wie diese Liebe dann den Niedergang erlebt haben. Wir haben im letzten Salon schon eine Autorin gehabt, die eine Ich-Erzählerin hat, die ihrem, ihren Kindern etwas erzählt. So auch hier wieder diese Perspektive. Und da ist es dann an einer Stelle, als es schon ein bisschen fortgeschritten ist. Und der Frühling kam und der Sommer, wie es eben geht, ob wir wollen oder nicht, wir wollten. Denn die Jahreszeiten sind außerhalb der Geschichte. Ein Rad, das sich dreht in dem expandierenden All, in dem wir so winzig sind. Und plötzlich war ein Jahr vergangen, seit der Nacht unserer ersten Begegnung. Und am Abend vor dem Jahrestag ging er aus dem Haus. Zum letzten Mal, sagte er, morgen will ich dir wieder begegnen, dort an der Bar im Planetarium. Am nächsten Nachmittag nahm ich ein Bad, trocknete mich ab und zog den Slip mit den kleinen grünen Rosen, mit den verpflasten Blättern an, die schwarze Strumpfhose, den schwarzen BH, das grüne Kleid und die schwarzen Schuhe, die ich in der ersten Nacht getragen hatte. Und zehn Minuten vor der Zeit stand ich schon an der Bar, als das kleine Mädchen, das ich nie wieder werde, schwerelos vor Erwartung, was nun geschehen würde. Und auf den Schlag genau tritt er ein und kommt auf mich zu. Und sein Blick, wie er mich sieht, sein Sphinx-Lächeln, und ich hätte es durchschauen sollen als das Theater, das es war, seine Vorstellung von einer anderen Welt als der gegebenen. Aber ich war bloß und wollte nichts anderes. Und er bleibt vor mir stehen, und das Universum hält den Atem an, und ich glaube, er will mich küssen, aber stattdessen sinkt er auf die Knie und nimmt meine Hand. Und dann stellt er mir die Frage, und ich sage Ja ohne Zögern oder Zweifel beinahe wie eine Puppe, und meine Stimme ist so schwach, als wollte ich nicht, dass sie sonst jemand hört. Aber irgendwas ist da schon zwischen den beiden vorgefallen. Irgendwie muss er auch einmal weg, und er geht aus diesem Stadium der Verliebtheit aus, weil er einen Termin hat. Ist da eigentlich schon alles verbrochen? Ist es überhaupt vielleicht ein Lehrerwahn, eine große Unmöglichkeit? Das ist das, was Madame Nielsen immer wieder verhandelt und hier auch wieder wunderbar auf 190 Seiten. Ich kann das sehr empfehlen, wenn man diesen rauschhaften Liebesroman lesen möchte.
Na dann verliebt euch alle beim Lesen. Das war der letzte Text des Salons, oder?
Nein, ich möchte noch ganz kurz auf das Interview mit Udo Kier hinweisen, dass ich gelesen habe in der GQ. Wirklich ein sehr langes Interview. Man kann es online lesen. Ich empfehle, das zu tun, wenn man sich ein bisschen für Filme interessiert und für Stars und Anekdoten. Udo Kier kommt aus einfachen Verhältnissen. Dann hat der Dechant in der Kirche, also katholisch, vorgeschlagen, naja, der könnte doch ins Kloster gehen. Und die Mutter hat gesagt, wir wollen den ins Kloster schicken und wir bezahlen das alles. Da kann der Abitur machen. Genau das war der Vorschlag, den die Mutter bekam. Udo Kier sagt, meine Mutter war begeistert. Aber mein Großvater hat meine Mutter angeschrien und gesagt, guck dir den Jungen doch mal an. Den kannst du doch nicht wegsperren, wie der aussieht mit den alten Männern da im Kloster. Denn Udo Kier sah sehr gut aus in jungen Jahren und hat das auch immer einzusetzen gewusst. Er hat dann angefangen, in einer Vorortfabrik zu arbeiten, aber er sagte auch, ich hatte das Glück, ein sehr fotogener junger Mann zu sein. Ob das jetzt Herr Krupp war, damals einer der reichsten Männer Deutschlands, oder Fürst Johannes von Thurn und Taxis, die haben mich ja alle gerne eingeladen, die wollten meine Anwesenheit. Und damit kukettiert er auch immer, dass er doch da enorm Eindruck machen konnte. Er gehörte, so heißt es dann bei dem Interviewer, zu den schönsten Männern der Welt, also mit Alain Delon und Helmut Berger. Und dann sagte er, und das würde ich noch gerade länger zitieren, da muss ich eine Geschichte erzählen. Mit dem Geld, das ich am Fließband verdient habe, bin ich nach London geflogen. Da war ein teurer Nachtclub, Denny La Rue. Da wollte ich immer rein. Ich hatte so viel davon gehört, dass da Provinenz ist. So, eines Nachts bin ich rein. Dann kam ein Kellner zu mir und sagte, Herr Visconti möchte Sie einladen auf ein Glas Champagner. Visconti, das war der berühmte italienische Regisseur, der zusammen war mit Helmut Berger. Der stand da mit Nouriev. Nouriev war der bedeutendste Balletttänzer im 20. Jahrhundert. Da habe ich dem Kellner gesagt, können Sie dem Herrn bitte ausrichten, er möge mich selbst fragen, anstatt sie zu schicken. Ja, da kam Visconti an meinen Tisch. Ganz furchtbares Englisch. Anyway, ich bin dann mitgegangen. Dann saß ich da mit meinen 19 Jahren in der Mitte zwischen Nouriev und Visconti. Am Tisch war auch noch ein schöner blonder junger Mann mit einem Akzent wie meinem. Da habe ich gesagt, wir beide können Deutsch sprechen. Dann sagte er ganz laut I am Austrian. Das war Helmut Berger. Ja, und dann fragte er Interviewer, wie war der Abend? Nouriev hat nur über seine Beine gesprochen. Er hat die ganze Zeit geklagt, wie müde seine Beine seien. Ich dachte, wo bin ich hier gelandet? Ich wusste ja erst nicht mal, was der mit seinen Beinen macht. Naja, ich bin mitgegangen in die Wohnung von Visconti. Als ich später ging, wollte er meine Adresse. Ganz geheimnisvoll. Ich schrieb sie auf eine Streichholzschachtel. Am nächsten Tag fuhr immer eine Limousine vor meiner kleinen Wohnung rum. Da habe ich mir schon gedacht, dass die irgendwie für mich ist. Da war der Chauffeur von Visconti. Der brachte mir ein kleines Geschenk von Cartier. Das war so ein Lesezeichen für Bücher aus Weißgold mit vier blauen Perlen. Habe ich leider nicht mehr, ist gestohlen worden. So war das also mit Visconti. Irgendwann kam ein Brief von ihm aus Paris.
Ja, da kann man richtig fühlen, wie du gerne dabei gewesen wärst.
Ja, und er kennt auch so alle Leute. Er ist mit David Hockney befreundet und er sagt auch, ich bin einer der wenigen Menschen, die Banksy kennen. Der war bei mir mit seiner Frau, die haben auch ein Kind. Malerei ist interessant, Film ist nicht meine Welt, es wurde meine Welt.
Echt, er kennt Banksy?
Ja.
Also gibt es Banksy? Das ist ja auch nicht schlecht zu wissen.
Offenbar. Oder Banksy ist Udo Kier, wer weiß.
Ja, das kann auch sein. Sehr gut, verrückt. Ja, das passt ein bisschen zu diesem durch Japan wandern und wissen, das ist bald vorbei. Also diese Momenthaftigkeit, die da drin steckt. Es ist ja wirklich zauberhaft, welche Geschichten da immer wieder erzählt werden. Sehr gut, damit ist auch der Salon April abgeschlossen. Und wir sehen uns dann Ende Mai wieder.
Genau, einen schönen Monat.
Und wir werden sehen, was der verrückte Monat hier noch bei sich hat. Bis denn.
Bis bald.